Five,
four,
three,
two live ladies.
Gentlemen.
A thousand episodes.
Tom Scorah,
Joey motherfucking Diaz.
We're,
we're delayed in starting.
Ladies and gentlemen.
We did not have a lighter.
That was a real panic set in.
That's embarrassing.
Yeah.
I thought I thought some shit was really
going to go down,
but thank God I am petrified of
earthquakes and situations.
I don't put slippers on.
I sleep with sneakers on generator,
a dog store.
Water,
water tools.
I got two weapons.
I got an a on.
Have you been out here for an
earthquake?
Uh,
one of them that didn't scare me but I
was just sitting by the computer and I
was looking at the cat bowls.
Yeah.
You get high and I was looking at the
cat.
So it was another cat bowls and all of a
sudden the whole building tip.
Sure.
The cat balls up in the air spinning and
the cats running for their lives.
They acted.
They were acting with a couple of
seconds before that.
And that's why I go.
Why are they so fucked up?
Oh,
they were acting weird before the earth
quarter your.
So I started looking at the cat bowls
dog stuff that they're doing that all of
a sudden the dog,
I just saw the cat bowls or it's like a
cartoon went up in the air spending the
earthquake and the whole building
shifted.
I heard the bricks,
the whole thing.
I told her about it being at night's
sleep apnea,
you gotta have a conveyor,
whatever the fuck.
And they sold for $600.
You get one with everything.
Lights an iron it fucking clean is your
water.
It's scary as shit when Shit,
you panic about what earthquakes are
likely if you,
when you before you move here,
you know,
and then you like,
I remember the first week I was here,
I was in an apartment in Sherman oaks
and I was standing at the kitchen
counter of this person's apartment on
their laptop doing like sending an email
and I felt a little and I go in my head,
I go,
oh,
that's the subway.
And I kept typing and then he could feel
that.
And I was like,
yeah.
And he's like crazy,
right?
That's the earth shake underneath your
feet.
And I was like,
ugh.
And it's like a panic sets in and you're
like,
oh my God,
like I've,
I've actually experienced the earth
moving now.
And then the next step is like when you
are,
you're like,
if you're asleep and then you hear like
you feel the dresser,
the dresser,
you know,
or,
or something that's hanging on your wall
bumping,
you know,
what the fuck's going on,
it takes you that extra beat to figure
out you're going through an earthquake.
That extra beat is fucked.
It's funny.
Have you been through?
Nothing big but like fives,
five point fives,
a couple of those.
The first one I was in was an aftershock
of the northridge earthquake.
I was uh,
staying in north Hollywood and I was in
this shitty apartment.
It was made out of like fucking the same
boxes that they used to ship
refrigerators and like literally the
walls when the earthquake hit the walls
just went to with this.
I mean,
like the whole thing was just like a
giant was pushing on the scariest.
Fuck,
right.
Yeah.
Well it's humbling because you realize
like,
this is nothing.
This isn't tune up the street,
this is not going over any houses.
Imagine what it felt like when that big
one hit and it hit for 30 seconds for
30,
30 seconds is so long to feel the ground
moving.
That's one of those people moved to
boulder.
That's why that was just going to say
that when you have that experience,
there's some people that because app for
a few days after the North Ridge,
there was aftershocks and there's people
that want.
They look at their kids and go,
I'm not going through this together and
we'll.
We're working on Wilshire big building.
What if house.
So a lot of people just a bad.
That's what everybody's waiting for an
earthquake here because then people
leave and they sell their houses for
dirt cheap.
But it does happen.
What gun?
They don't ever want to experience it
again.
But then I see a guy like my uncles
lived here 55 and I've asked him,
were you ever scared?
And he goes,
you know,
you're feeling but do.
When I first moved here,
before I first moved here,
I was out here for meetings and I went
by a section of the highway,
I think it was the 10 that had collapsed
and they were moving cars around it and
as we are.
Is this what happened?
Yeah.
What is this an apartment building that
collapsed the North Ridge earthquake in
northridge.
One.
Yeah,
dude,
that was a fucking serious earthquake,
man.
Yeah,
like fucking serious.
And when I was driving by this one
section of the highway,
it collapsed on the lower section and I
remember thinking that's just shit luck
like this right here.
Yeah.
Like you could be there and that is just
shitload is really the thing lands on
you and that's how you go.
I'm sorry.
I am a hardworking individual.
I really try to do anything I could to
help myself.
But when people call me,
telling me they want me to go to a
meeting in Santa Monica after like
three,
unless I'm picking up an envelope,
I tell them no matter that kid won the
Oscar for modern family and they said I
was always the guy that went to ocean
avenue,
would five of those were additions.
You deserve an Oscar because when you
switched from the 10 zero five,
you've got to wait on that ramp first
world privilege right there,
fucking high and you're in the middle of
that ramp.
Your mind starts playing.
I'm telling you,
I've been stuck on that ramp.
I mean,
I've gone never get a man.
I just want to go through this ramp.
I don't ever want to be in the middle of
that ramp.
That's not good.
Not Good.
Your mind starts playing with you and
you remember that goes into images and
you go,
fuck that.
Okay,
let me.
Let's plan this right now.
If the shit hits the fan,
this thing shakes to the ground.
Where are we going?
[inaudible]?
Listen,
one of the main reasons why I like being
in La is because I like you guys.
Yeah,
so we're going to all go like I like for
real,
like 100 percent like that.
That was the thing that bothered me the
most about Colorado.
I,
there was a lot of Nice people out
there,
but I didn't know you guys weren't out
there.
It's a weird feeling when we work
together on,
but there's something fun about running
into you guys all the time.
Like it makes life better.
We do send it to the store,
the factory in wherever we're at,
we're.
It's more fun.
It makes life more fun.
This podcast,
100 percent I would do it.
Group moved to Colorado.
That's what I'm talking about.
State.
That's what we do.
The group moved to.
Colorado is the right way.
You've got to remember guys.
It's not a decision that it could be.
You go home.
Mrs Rogan sits you down and go,
that's it.
I'm not living this.
Yeah,
that's what.
That's how.
In fact,
I packed the bags,
get back Colorado without a whole cow.
People.
It affects that way.
Oh yeah,
but they go like this ends today with
that,
with that earthquake.
Some you feel it.
If you feel that motherfucker,
the ones that take down highways,
if you feel that you're like,
oh my God,
like,
and this is not even a really big one.
Really big ones changed the shape of
continence.
True.
I mean that's the real fear.
The real fear is,
is a giant one,
like a 10 or an 11 part of you by the
way always feels kind of crazy.
Like when I was growing up in Florida
with hurricanes that like after a
hurricane you're like,
are we staying after?
This happens all the time.
That's Florida Florida's mentality.
Like we just brought up a good beer,
but there's a hurricane that for
whatever reason I feel like if you just
in the basement,
the top blows off the thing and you just
fucking strapped.
Or sometime like a wild ride at
Disneyland,
but now they give you these warnings.
They're like,
you're definitely going to die.
You're at the beach and people still are
like,
fuck it.
Yeah.
Oh,
for sure.
My friend's mom,
his mom is like 70 something years old
and this big one was coming.
They're like,
this time we're not fucking around,
this is a category five,
this is going to absolutely devastate
this area.
And she was like,
absolutely not.
I've been here 40 something years,
nothing ever fucking happens.
And he begged her and she was like,
no.
And it's like,
you know,
those are all those reports are always
rolling the dice because they,
they'll,
they'll say it's going to be this bad
and then it'll,
you know,
it'll turn or to land different.
Yeah.
And it turned into like a tropical
storm.
She was safe.
She was like the only person that stayed
like everybody else.
We would always bail.
I don't know if you were ever there for
hurricane.
No,
but like we would always book it man.
As soon as they were like,
this thing is going to land,
we're like,
no,
there's no way.
And even driving in those tropical
storms was an real men.
Like you can't see an inch in front of
the car.
It's like you're driving through a car
wash.
We had to stop once.
Will you with me?
When Eddie did that seminar in Miami
when we were working at West Palm.
Did you go down with us?
No,
we went.
We Eddie's doing a seminar in West Palm
or in in Miami.
We're in West Palm.
It's like a half hour away,
so we left to go to the seminar and we
were stopped dead on the highway.
You could not see an inch in front of
the windshield.
It's amazing.
It lasted for about 15 minutes,
but it was too damn sky opened up the
time there all the time.
We don't even know what rain is.
No,
we don't even know and I never knew
growing up,
like in Boston growing up,
growing up in Boston,
I never saw that we saw it rain.
We never saw that.
That's some next level.
I haven't really seen it duplicated
since leaving there.
It's pretty crazy child.
I saw one bad rainstorm in Jersey with a
cloud's got dark.
Yeah.
It started hailing.
Well.
Have you been looped through Halan,
Colorado as well as the videos of what?
People's cars are just coming around it
and there's one guy,
one guy had a film of a lake,
they were watching it and it slowly
ramps up.
It's like one,
two,
one,
and he's like,
well,
look at the size of this hail,
and then all of a sudden it's fun.
It's literally like being attacked with
rocks from space.
Like,
look at this pool.
Yeah,
there's a gang of these men,
but like,
look at this one that that's rock rocks.
It fucks people's cars.
Destroys,
destroys call,
and that was just happening to Colorado
water dude.
Thousand roofers moved to Colorado
because there's work for two fucking
years.
Can you look at it?
It's getting worse.
This is insane,
dude.
You get K okay.
Especially if you're like a little kid.
Oh,
definitely.
Being a five year old out in this
fucking pummeled to death.
Does anybody ever died from Hale?
Has to have happened.
Seems like it stops the girl.
The first week I moved to Atlanta Monday
and that Friday was the north Hollywood
shootout.
Oh,
I'm not sure that we've got that Monday.
I came in.
I was living with Stan.
Yeah.
Went to find the job that Friday and
there was a bunch of traffic and they
were like,
Nah,
there's north Hollywood shooting north
Hollywood shootout changed policing
nationwide.
You know that that incident changed the
way they viewed having weapons changed
their training.
They never even competent contemplated
that people would rob a bank with like
fully automatic.
You're coming up with the body,
but just fucking blind.
It was laying by a car after he was hit
just shooting up at helicopters and
shit.
That was fucking crazy,
man.
I remember that national news that was
just like a big.
You couldn't get on the one on one.
I was in the news radio break room.
We were,
we were getting ready to film a scene
and we're watching me and candy
Alexander huddled up together going,
what the fuck?
Everybody came in,
guys get in here,
get in here.
But they're all in.
They're watching.
They're like,
what in the fuck?
And it changed the way they,
uh,
what kind of tactics they use and the
equipment they give police absolutely
did 38 SPEC.
Then they still reference it all the
time.
I did a ride along two months ago with
the Hollywood division dude and I was a
guy was still talking about.
He's like,
we have this because
of this shootout.
The end,
you know,
that's a lot of people say,
Oh man,
fuck in the militarization of the
police,
man.
This is what.
There's a lot of it that's not good.
You give to people too much power.
It's not good,
but if some shit happens like that,
they need that.
Otherwise they're sitting ducks.
Yeah,
kind of weapons.
You get on the streets right now.
Oh Dude,
you only fuck crazy shit.
Fire firepower.
You get on the streets from Ar 15 and
you get some wild shit on the fucking
street.
Yeah.
Oh,
you have to do.
Is this number two real quick
mathematics for anybody's interested.
There's $350 million people somewhere
around in this country.
There's more guns in there are people
and they're still making guns everyday.
They make guns.
There's a gun making industry.
It's gigantic.
They're making all kinds of guns all
over the country.
Right?
Every year,
like every other,
maybe more higher tech.
Not Getting rid of any guns?
No.
Like all those guns for toys.
Oh,
give back to your gun and you'll get a
toy.
Okay.
And then yourself?
Someone who's a factory going on right
now.
They're cranking out ar as compassion
and one person like,
here you go.
Some rusty old,
22 fucking handball court.
But you get anything like jumping.
Right?
I can't believe they're playing
handball.
Still dedicated to handball who's like,
I'm going to be the best.
When you get out of prison doing prison,
they play handball.
So when you get out your claim
disability,
you play handball and it's to cover for
you that you were half a momo,
but you play handball.
So guns that kill,
you'll get a gun at a handball court for
$50.
That's shot three people that God has
missed a motherfucking a motherfucking
charlotte was so a motherfucker
committed suicide.
Long range with those guns.
They don't give a fuck.
They got guns that don't miss that.
Handball courts.
Did you play?
You play handball in prison that you
said?
I played handball like the first two
weeks.
That just wasn't for me.
You played in Colorado and because there
was a few guys from the Bronx,
so when I went to summit county,
because I was arrested in boulder,
but once you start your state sentence,
they were going to send me to the
Missouri or Texas.
I ended up going to summit county.
Summit County is like,
we don't really have bars.
Yeah,
don't know.
You could just do what you want here.
Yeah.
At night at 10:00,
the God would go to the pathmark
pathmark like a supermarket and get his
chips and soda.
It was like a fucking daycare.
Wow.
Everyone got along pretty well.
You're a young guy with a dude from the
bronx that played handball and we became
friends together.
He had been on the run for 12 years,
but this guy was brilliant.
He was fucking brilliant.
Like the shit he had done.
He had driven the cop's car,
like,
what's that movie Leonardo Dicaprio cash
pay for your care.
That he was that guy and the final thing
he did for them was if they caught him
and he set them up on the drugs thing,
like I read the paperwork.
It was brilliant.
He set him up on a drug drugs thing.
He said,
I know where I could go buy 10 kilos of
coke.
The cops actually gave him $250,000
cash to buy the 10 kilos of coke.
He set it up with his friend,
didn't have a car behind the house.
The car was empty,
the house was empty.
There was no cops.
Never even did a background check to see
who lived in the house.
Jesus the house was empty.
He went through the front and went out
the back and disappeared.
Travel for 10 years and he came back to
the states because his dad died and they
arrested him.
He took a million years ago.
He went for like a rubric and just
played shuffleboard.
Handball.
That's a dark world.
The world of the ex.
Pat?
No,
South American tourists communities.
Yeah.
That's like that.
Or a sizable too,
right?
I mean all over.
All over Mexico.
There's a lot of people in Brazil and I
had a friend that South American dad was
a island hopping all throughout his
adolescence just to avoid taxes,
just to avoid taxes.
And then the crazy thing to me is that
is that they came here like they came
back eventually and so is he in trouble?
And he's like,
no,
how is he not in trouble?
He was like,
I don't know,
why aren't they going to catch him?
And he's like,
no,
what do you mean man?
Like he's here now.
Like is that a whole new identity?
No,
just don't worry about does he paid
taxes?
He said No.
And he's like,
well he doesn't,
she still does.
And then my friend was still like,
you know,
you don't have to pay taxes.
And I was one of those guys.
He goes,
ah.
Google it.
It's like you have to pay taxes when
that's your thing.
Like just look it up man.
God Damn it.
Pay Your taxes to lock you up so quick.
It doesn't matter if you pay them.
See if you owe money to say like Exxon,
you know,
whatever,
they'll sue you.
You have to pay the money.
You paid the money.
But if the irs,
if you owe money to the irs,
they put you in a fucking cage for sure.
Godless of if you pay,
let's say,
even if you don't,
even if you agree to pay it,
say,
yeah,
you're going to go in a cage first.
Yeah,
no,
pay your company money.
They file a judgment against you and
then they sell the paper and then you
get called a comedy clubs.
Like I used to,
you know,
when I first started comedy,
I owed so much money.
Did you really go to a comedy club?
The manager goes,
you just got a call to recall,
and I go,
Holy Shit.
If Hbo really like collection,
collect my mind,
that would go with HBO.
Oh Shit.
I don't ever go joey.
It's the same guy and I'd pick up the
phone.
Joey a discover card.
We never got that payment.
Motherfucker.
Why fucking figure it out.
They have tremendous scabs.
Are People looking for you?
They have a computer that they'll go on
to see what other numbers that usually
call you and they'll get that number
when they call you,
that number will come up over your
caller id.
They do some illegal shit when they're
looking for you,
but when you get a judgment from exon
seven years,
you don't pay it.
It goes away.
The government,
that judgment never goes away.
That the student loan these
motherfuckers to tell student loans to
suck that Dick.
Oh yeah.
Student loans come even more intense by
arrest.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
that's all the government as well.
That's the thing about student loans is
it doesn't get erased when you go to
bankruptcy.
If you filed for bankruptcy,
anything else is gone.
You know,
I pay the student loan.
I thought it was cute.
I took the last one out.
The Twenty six,
25 the minimum.
Fuck you.
I've done a couple of people.
They showed up about three years ago.
Dog with a big old number.
I had to get an attorney to negotiate it
down and get off at the irs.
I didn't pay taxes from 90 to 2001 was
talking.
I was crazy.
I was hiding.
I was doing.
What was that?
Making 8,000
years of road common.
Yeah.
What am I going to file?
So I didn't file.
I made money one of the 13 years or 11
years and one day I walked in downtown
downtown that we're going to shoot me in
that.
I took a number.
They called my name.
I went back there.
I told them I hadn't filed them 11
years.
They asked me what I did.
I talked to a lady for a half hour.
She had.
She goes,
we don't go back for seven,
so you got seven for years.
Now they don't throw you and listen.
You have to be a dumb motherfucker for
them to throw you in jail or you have to
be a public figure.
They give you every option.
Jonah,
the public figure,
you're actually worse off than if you're
just legitimate businessman.
If you a public thing.
I could go down there with my attorney
and said,
look,
I'm going to shoot 10 movies and the
next time they wouldn't.
They would not let Wesley snipes do that
because we gave him such a hard.
At first he was telling them all this
shit that FEC rules and fuck the United
States,
Africa,
and he was talking about all that shit
and that shit drives them crazy.
I don't think he.
He was.
He made a case that he didn't owe them.
You got to go in there humble and
they'll play with you once you start
talking about amendment 11,
Thomas Jefferson,
reparations,
Chinese reserves.
Don't give a fuck those people out there
that convinced people that they don't
have to pay taxes and people want to
believe it,
like a conspiracy theory.
You know?
It might be,
here's the thing,
you might have a legal argument,
but it doesn't matter.
They'll put you in a fuck.
Can't get away.
Carriage tax,
evasion that money and put you in a
fucking cage and you won't make any
money from fucking the solution.
What's that?
That kid that we miss?
Illusion is that situation.
Whatever his fucking name is.
Let me get a tissue paper from.
Yeah,
he's a nice guy.
He's a really nice guy.
Very nice guy.
Wait,
what happened to him?
He tried to.
He actually didn't just not pay his
taxes.
There were some shenanigans,
contended he made less than he actually
did get you on why these pete rose's and
they got sinbad,
remember that they were putting them on
the front page of the La Times for years
wise or dog Mike.
The situation.
More charges.
Yeah.
Coding,
tax evasion and structuring tax evasion.
Like once you structure it and you're
the mastermind a,
you're definitely going the farm.
The
craziest part of the story was to me
that for that period that they're like
hitting them up about he made $9.
Million million dollars.
So friendly.
No,
I just was amazed that I didn't realize
that from.
I mean I remember that show obviously a
huge hit,
but that's incredible sum of money.
We should really pay attention to this.
Like not just his but what,
what they can do.
Because you think about what it is is
we're just talking about money.
Right.
And we're talking about some deception
on his part where he tried to keep some
money.
Yeah.
Try to make them look like anybody else.
I say,
or you're in some sort of a deal with
costco and he'd do some sneaky shit and
just that they,
they can sue you,
neil owe them and you have to pay them,
but there's no threat of jail time.
Right,
right.
I mean,
is there,
have you tried to like cook the books?
Would they get just what they put you in
jail or were they just trying to find
why fraud a today finds I'm guessing be
the same kind of scrutiny and attention
now that he's getting?
No,
I think it'd be all about paying a lot
of money.
Let's,
let's put,
let's pretend that Mike Sorrentino,
was that his name?
Let's pretend that he had some sort of a
deal Chevrolet and uh,
you know,
he was using his name to sell cars,
but he was fucking around with some
money and cooking the books and little
bit of this,
a little bit of that to the same tune as
what was going on with the irs.
What do you think they would do to him?
Would you even be seeing this on TV now?
They would,
yeah.
It'd be like a suit,
right?
Because what they're saying is this guy
tried to fuck that big daddy,
right?
I mean that's what they're showing you,
showing you that big daddy gets mad when
you try to fuck him.
And in the grand scheme of things like
in a lot of money for an individual to
earn,
but it's,
you know,
it's not money that affects big daddy.
Daddy's coming after you.
But here's the strange thing,
big daddy is just people like,
well,
why don't we let anything be big daddy?
Like the,
I,
we used to think of it I think from like
almost like a primitive perspective.
Like you have a king,
you know,
or you have a leader of a tribe.
I think that's,
that's how people used to think of it
and used to think of all these
organizations,
whether it's the FBI or the dea as being
a part of that,
but there are just a bunch of fucking
people and no,
no person should ever be big daddy to
the point where if you have money that's
owed to someone else,
perhaps there's some sort of an argument
that you've been deceptive that they can
just swoop down and take all your money.
Like they lock it all up like they're
go,
no,
no.
We're fucking freezing your funds.
Like Exxon doesn't get to do that.
Chevy doesn't get to do that over other
corporations don't get to do that,
but big daddy has the overall say if you
violate big daddy's code,
even though big daddy like you don't
need you to get a receipt from,
from big Daddy,
big daddy,
half your money and big daddy just takes
it and spends as fuck.
You want to whatever the fuck they want.
And you know,
you said you don't pay taxes.
You fucking hippie.
What are you a Bernie Sanders supporter?
Not even saying that,
not even saying that,
I think,
don't you think big data should be
accountable if big daddy's gonna be able
to just throw us in a cage because we
don't give him ones and zeroes don't
think big daddy should be a little bit
accountable.
Should be way accountable for their
spending
way more accountable.
Hey,
you shouldn't just,
you should be able to check off boxes
to.
There should be like still like needs
like healthcare check,
like a police department,
check fire department check things that
you.
We all like have to pay and then there
should be elective things.
A bunch of elective shit.
You know,
I feel like they should also like our
representatives should be way more
willing and like actually like mandated
to explain in detail and like what
they're doing,
what they're spending on it.
I feel like a lot of,
you know,
house represent Congress Senate.
There's just like an air of arrogance
about the way that they even handle
them.
You know what I mean?
They have power.
Of course they are big daddy,
big daddy and like it's.
Yeah,
I mean it's just like aloofness that
they have is like,
it's always been upsetting to him.
It's fucking gross.
No one should be big daddy and you mean
the,
the people in Congress should be humble
and you know,
that's one of the things about Obama.
Say what you want about Obama,
whether you liked his policies as a
human being.
That guy conducted himself better than
any president ever.
The way he spoke,
the way he interacted with people,
the way he even responded to criticism,
you know,
we're not just talking,
I'm not talking about his policies and
you might hate to clap for them,
be as good as it's ever been,
which is why this trump thing is in such
direct contrast.
When he's yelling the other day,
it's some reporter and he said,
uh,
you know,
you're fake news.
He used that again.
Oh Man.
He said,
be quiet.
Fake news or something like that.
We're talking about something,
you know,
we can conflate the two,
like if you want to take,
talk about policy and effectiveness of
it administration and just personal
conduct.
Like let's say you take all the politics
out of it.
That's what bothers a lot of people to
this moment still if you just even
separate politics,
which a lot of people are in favor of
just the way he conducts himself.
Some people love it.
Listen,
let's be honest.
So it's very,
very small amount of people love it,
but a lot of people are on president.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You were saying before there's no
debtor's prison.
Yeah,
there's no debtor's prison.
When I first got into comedy,
I was getting divorced.
I was getting squeezed by an attorney
and as much as i.
I never forget the first day,
I haven't missed sending a payment or
anything.
Like I'll never forget how sugar that my
credit rating and everything.
I worked all those years going down the
toilet and then at that point is if I'm
walking on nights,
I might as well dance.
I mean I was just buying cars and
fucking around and know what.
They couldn't throw me in jail for all
that shit,
but one discovery closed my account.
Yeah.
And I went home and opened up my drone.
One of those,
because when you,
when you want coke,
you get fucking Einstein,
creative Jack.
I went home and I opened the drawer and
I saw all those checks.
Those three checks with discover sends
you.
When you first went to card,
get the card.
I had a bank account to Bank of Boulder
or whatever it was called.
I had my back,
my car finance through that.
I
wouldn't have had a 24 hour drive
through.
I wouldn't at 1:00
and signed that check over to myself for
a thousand.
I waited for two seconds and all of a
sudden envelope came out with a 100 with
10 hundreds.
I peeled them,
did 90 out of the discover call,
said you got an hour to bring that
fucking money back or we're going to
charge you with fraud.
And I was put up against the thing.
I went to the bank.
I told them it was a mistake I didn't
know and one lady said,
you know what?
I'll take that thousand dollars.
I will give you the thousand,
but I'm going to put it into your car
loan and raise the payments by 25 bucks
for every thousand dollars,
25 bucks,
and that's the only reason why I didn't
go to jail for that fucking thing.
So they don't put you in jail for being
in debt.
They put you in jail for deception.
You know how they get athletes and
entertainers.
You know what that biggest downfall is
when they go to comic cons and those
autograph signings.
Oh they don't.
They don't get paid for.
Those are they get paid for those don't
report.
There's two things.
There's the people who get $5,000
flat and you take pictures all day.
Then there's the people that get $10 for
their tee shirt and $15 for a headshot
and a smile.
Yep.
Those 15 that I was going in your
pocket,
Bro.
You know what I'm saying?
And what happens is you have to give a
percentage to that $15 to the guy.
It's like when you sell a merchant at a
comedy club,
now all of a sudden now they want 80
percent of your merchant.
Same thing.
Well that guy reports it,
but pete rose.
I'm just saying Pete Rose,
I have nothing against Rosie.
My dog,
Pete rose.
We just put $15 in his pocket,
right?
What?
$60 or he took 10 pictures.
It's $150.
That's how they get you on all those
autograph things.
What's going on here?
What's this is from an article.
That's what he's talking about.
This article is talking about walking
away from comic con with garbage bags
full of twenties.
This guy said he can make up to 250
grand shit twice.
They didn't feel a need for
representation because he's walking out
with a bag full of cash.
What?
Who is he?
It's like an unnamed person.
He's a source.
Deeply involved.
The Steven Arnelle who became so
enhanced the festival business that he
started his talent.
Talented.
You see the Arrow to show the arrow.
Oh,
okay.
Comic book show on Netflix.
Wow.
That's a lot of money.
Fuck,
that seems very strange.
Comic Con,
you pay for a booth and then I think
you've given me three percent of the
overall take.
Don't you think?
That's really bizarre.
Having people pay to come and meet you.
That seems weird.
Strange.
I think it's weird to charge somebody
for a picture and,
and charge somebody to sign.
I mean,
I guess the signing thing,
I understand there's a bit,
especially in sports,
you know,
business selling a book,
but um,
or visa or thing that you're signing
$500,000
a weekend.
Who the fuck gets that from the walking
dead?
Norman Reedus $200,000
guarantee to back guarantee p 500 grand
a weekend follow celebrities will get a
flat and the ones that are the way real
low,
like if you want Lucille Ball,
like if you want happy days or something
like that,
they get piecework.
I just changed my mind.
I'm all in doing the next weekend.
I'm taking pictures with your mom,
your kid,
you would never do this.
Joe Rogan,
like the other day,
a friend of mine called me and he goes,
I was at my dad's hospital room the
other day and it was the funniest thing.
Joe Rogan,
a young Joe Rogan sitting around a
campfire with people.
He goes,
I never saw that episode,
and all of a sudden he pulls out a bag
of dicks and he made every believer.
He dixie goes,
me and my dad would fucking Howard,
you know,
for some people in 10 years they're
going to come to you and say,
can I get to take a picture for $10?
I love the fact that we.
And you're sit back on one picture now.
I understand.
I think it's a bad relationship.
It is,
but some people when they go to Comicon,
yeah,
they take their whole savings out there
ready to go.
Now I'm sure I understood the shame.
I understand the chain,
but I can make a living.
What are you gonna do?
I don't have any problem with it.
I don't have any problem.
People do want to make a living know who
I was.
Just saying.
That's how you get nailed.
That's how they nail you.
Don't get that.
Could you see yourself doing that?
Talking to them back.
That's what I'm saying.
Listen,
when I was a coke fiend,
like sell cds after a show.
So what,
what does that tell you?
Why I couldn't yet.
I have to embarrass.
Wow.
I have a hard time.
I'd rather shake your hand and hug you.
I can get the fuck out then you not come
up to me because I'm selling a $25 seat
there.
Yeah,
that's a funny thing about you joey.
You know?
Uh,
I've,
I've been friends with a lot of guys
that had substance abuses.
Like I told you about my friend Johnny
back in New York.
And one thing that you both had in
common is that even though you have like
these issues,
there was never a point where I felt
like I couldn't trust you with
something.
You know,
like I,
you,
you never would sell anybody out.
You would never,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
you know,
you're not a type of person who would do
something to hurt somebody else so that
you could profit because you were sick
and you needed drugs.
That was never you.
You always had like a strong code of
ethics.
Get out that you were worth nothing.
I was a jam that had problems,
but when are we started telling people
he's a junkie but he pays his bills.
Will you?
Will you know like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
You're just a guy struggling in and I
recognized he knew a lot of what I had
seen in my friend Johnny was that
there's a lot of people that are
brilliant people that for some reason
the fabric of society just doesn't fit.
That just is.
There's something about getting up in
the morning and go into a job and you
know,
whatever it is about the way they were
raised to experiences they had,
just who they are inherently from
whatever the
factors are there.
Certain people that just can't do the
regular thing and they just need to find
this other thing for you is obviously
stand up and once you found that other,
the thing and became successful,
that other thing,
that's when your whole thing changed.
That's when you were.
I mean,
it was really proved positive.
I mean for sure.
You learned a lot of things about life.
You got older,
you get wiser,
you know,
but I think a big part of you becoming
more comfortable and more relaxed and
becoming who you are today is that you,
you started becoming successful as a
comedian.
And when you started becoming successful
as a comedian,
like,
well,
10 years ago things started really
ramping up for Ya.
Uh,
noticeable,
relaxing,
a few noticeable change because you,
you,
you realize like,
oh,
this is what I'm supposed to be doing.
The problem is when this isn't working.
And then you think,
well,
maybe I should go back to selling cars.
Or maybe I should get a job in a
factory.
Maybe I should.
Maybe I should do something a three or
four nights a week.
Just bartend.
Make a little extra money,
lighten up the load on the family that
when those types of things start fucking
with you and that's when you start doing
coke.
That's when you start going crazy.
That's when you stay up late.
That's when you fuck off.
That's when you make big mistakes.
Like you're unhappy,
you're upset,
you're in the wrong groove.
It wasn't the external struggles as much
as the internal struggle or maybe all of
it together.
No violent this November,
so it'd be 10 years.
I haven't done a lot of coke and coffee.
It's amazing
with you.
The January after the November and
you're like,
you haven't done it in 60 days and that
was still.
I wasn't sweating it out.
Yeah,
but I still wasn't trusting myself.
Right.
I thought I could snap at any minute,
some chicklet hot pits with a gram of
coke or whatever,
but you gotta remember Bro.
For me it wasn't about success or or
selling tickets or for me it was just
doing something with my life where I've
come from.
All I wanted was just to do something
with my life.
If I could pay rent,
feed the cats,
smoke pot and do spots,
that's a lot better than what I used to
do.
Yeah.
That's how a lot better than when the
life I had you understand that even if I
don't go on the road and I'm not Louis,
c,
k,
it didn't matter to me.
Just that I didn't have to carry a gun
or worry about people knocking on my
door.
I was like Richard Gere and Austin's
gentlemen.
I had nowhere else to go to the store
and do that stupid spot at 12,
45 and look what happened.
You just keep showing up.
Yeah man,
there was a big part of it,
but another big part of it was getting
you on the Internet.
That was the thing.
So we get a chance to show people what I
already knew.
You know,
with like the only way for you back then
to get exposure was you had to do
something conventional.
The only thing that existed,
they had to put you in a movie or put
you in a TV show and you got an a few
movies,
movies and you got an a few TV shows,
but they didn't get to see you as Joey d
and c,
but they got to cut some fucking
character actor and you know that mob
movie with Robert De Niro.
But there's a big difference between
that and you like this.
You just took the.
Took the right thing for you to be this.
You took like the Internet,
but the Internet has like for Joey is
the best medium ever.
Yeah,
for sure.
It was exploded.
Well for you to know it's gone.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
Like it.
I like it.
You're just as good of an example.
Like you don't have a lot of success
outside of the Internet.
No,
that's true.
The Internet has been your shit man.
I mean think about it.
You didn't have like a long running
television series or a series of movies
or anything you do,
but you're selling out places that a lot
of those guys can't even fuck with all
the time because of your podcast,
which is if you haven't seen it,
it's your podcast with your wife.
It's one of my favorite podcasts.
It's so fucking consistently silly.
That is so ridiculous and people get
silly when they get on it.
They do and then you know,
I start seeing things like,
oh,
this is like your mom's house bit.
I need to send it to Tom.
Yeah,
you sent me a couple of good ones.
I can tell a story about taking this
shit without 90 people hitting me up the
next day telling me that was the most
brilliant story in the world.
We're going to send it to Tom.
Tom.
I tell her shit.
Shit comic.
It's awesome.
Bought myself something.
Discussed two days later.
Sure enough,
I'm the fucking youtube videos.
Played Joey telling shit stories for
sure and he told us about when he shit
in his backyard and somebody thought it
was got the lady she leave.
She will let her dogs out everyday and
she would clean up.
They will French poodles dogs.
It was just as high up in the air,
just reeling back from this shit,
this shit.
Joe Rogan.
She looked at it and she was like 58.
So she's squinting at this shit up
against the wall.
I took a shit and I put my back against
the wall.
So when I shift,
when you shit outside,
it's not going to be a decent shit.
It's going to be like explosive.
So when I got up it looks like somebody
got shot in the head that we should all
behind me.
So she's sitting there with a little
French poodles,
Chihuahuas and she's looking at the wall
like,
what the fuck happened?
Then all of a sudden she actually walks
up to close to it and squint and look at
it and looks around and runs it.
I'm watching all this.
I can't breathe.
And now I go to the computer because my
wife's very decent sitting there for
half and then my wife comes in and she
goes,
were you home all day today?
I go,
yeah,
why?
She goes,
I just had a conversation with Susan.
She wanted to know if you heard anything
in the back yard.
Then I went to get Sushi,
but give it a go get Sushi.
I eat a lot of it.
Hey,
the rice pushes everything out.
Yeah.
You had plans to go get a weed store.
You will go to the post office.
But I made a detour.
I plan to go home,
but I left the house key in the house so
I had to climb around the window.
That's what happened.
Yeah.
So when I pulled myself up,
I actually landed with my stomach on the
window and now you've made it push it
out more like fuck.
And my hands are struggling in the
window and my feet are on the other side
and the cat's scratching at me.
Right.
And I might get to me.
So I ran out,
ran down the stairs,
shit outside.
Oh my God.
Nobody took a shit in favor in his
backyard after a five hour drive from
Colton or some weird town and not talk
to you.
After that for awhile I took a shit and
then he ran over.
It was called backyard.
Smelled like sewage.
He goes,
it smells back here.
Let's walk in the house.
I don't know what happened and you can
see the brown shit.
He smashed it with this tire and a bunch
of flyers or talked to me for a month
after that shit in somebody's backyard
because I told him the truth.
I felt bad.
That's hard to clean up.
Yeah.
Shit,
dog shit.
It doesn't even make you gag like human
shit.
Bomb Shit to clean up some wine.
Oh Shit.
If you had to use one of those scrapers.
Yeah.
It smells so much stronger,
man.
It's so much.
No,
no,
no.
When you kick a shit until you cut it in
half when that.
When that reese's peanut butter fume
leaks out.
Oh my God.
He's like,
I've done studies.
When you go to jail,
when you,
when you go to prison you have to cut
the shit,
the shit like in the tube,
but people watching TV,
like when you go to county jail you shit
right there.
So black guys will be laying there
watching TV with their feet up and also
this little shit and they're like put
some water in that whole motherfucking
like they'll just yell at the other side
of the fucking prison because that means
you,
you took a shit and just sitting there.
So imprisoned as soon as you shit you
got to put water on it.
Yeah.
But then some bathrooms that only give
you 20 ounces of water a day.
So whatever time you flush,
it's got to be a good flush.
You follow me.
So sometimes the pis has to stay there
until the next day until you take a good
good shit.
But when you take a shit in jail bro,
that's what they'll tell you because of
water with some hole in that
motherfucking old dog.
I could smell that shit.
Right now I'm trying to watch oprah,
but that's what smells.
One stuff sucks.
It's like when you go to Vegas to have
that sucking action.
If took the ship is
big.
That's 34 inches once it breaks and it
looks like two new jobs.
Once that breaks,
it's over.
It's over.
And they put the bathroom right by the
door.
The front entrance?
Yeah.
That have nobody come over.
That's why I always go downstairs,
take shit.
I don't Shit in my bathroom,
in the hotel no more because it kills
the whole room for two hours.
We worked at the House of Blues in Vegas
and uh,
Joey left a,
an onshore shit.
You know what onshore shit is like,
he,
he was so fat at the time that he
couldn't sit down and like the regular
toilet.
You were like,
what were you four slash 15?
He was giant.
Giant.
So when he would take a shit,
he would had have to balance himself
mostly on the very edge of the front
because his ass was so big.
Wide Shit in the water on the deck.
No.
Oh,
so you ain't never seen shit like that
before.
So you couldn't sit in the toilet.
I would sit on the toilet,
but I don't like the ad.
It wasn't that I was fat.
I don't like my dick inside the toilet.
Right.
Suck his dick and off the toilet.
I tell my wife,
don't even let my wife be in public
because I want to eat her monkey.
I don't want that monkey touching the
other thing.
So when I shit in a public bathroom,
I hope my balls and I shit towards the
edge.
I don't give a fuck in somebody else's
backyard.
So your soul,
your balls and sit where you are because
none of them to move forward because if
I'm back there,
I got grabbed one time sitting on the
toilet.
They'll jump from that toilet inward
like they jumping over a month.
People who are saying they got crabs to
the toilet isn't an excuse.
Well,
sometimes you can create crabs from
anywhere,
but why they it take it from here?
They only cleaned the hairs.
I don't think they're like little stay
on an actual toilet.
I think probably.
Definitely.
Right?
Yeah.
I would feel like that's one of the
things about crabs.
I took a shot at the gas station that
had to be at.
That's what I haven't figured it was.
I'm sorry.
I always hold my shit.
My Shit.
It was long and red band.
Put Ketchup on it.
Remember red band?
We'll catch up.
Unfortunately.
I think that was a different time.
Okay.
This is not happening.
It has been many,
many times.
Things just like sticking out of go in
there.
There's a smell.
You know how when you take an epic shit,
it's an above water shit.
It comes out like,
like the fucking big island of Hawaii
just rises through the water.
Like I've done that many times because I
eat too much now and I'll take these
shifts that are just so big.
They're preposterous,
but there's a totally different smell to
those shits because you're smelling raw
shit outside of the water.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's gone through the water and it's
poking into the wrong.
What is it about that that makes you
happy?
What is it about the sense of
accomplishment?
First of all,
here's a good one,
right?
It doesn't come around that often
either.
Yeah,
man.
It's like a comment like and it just
like,
I don't.
This doesn't happen all the time.
It's always diarrhea too.
It's never like.
It's never like a super thick law.
It's weird when the second wave is
diarrhea.
Like when you take a shit,
you're proud of yourself and then you're
like,
I think I got a little more in there.
And it's like,
God,
it's just a fucking,
you know,
that's from what healthy eating,
healthy eating does that.
Yeah.
If you eat some mct oil or coconut oil,
lubes up your pipes because where I
moved to them and have the office to
back office and it's connected to a
backroom.
It's got a door so I don't live with
distinct no more.
I opened the door in the morning with
backyard.
I shit.
I smoked a bowl backyard anymore.
No,
no,
no.
My dog goes faces to the backyard.
I had my own bathroom and the bedroom.
Then don't put a woman through one of
your shit's back there.
Yeah.
Leave her alone.
Opened the back door.
Fuck the fuck.
I just opened the back door.
This is school behind their kids
playing.
I'm shitting and smoking dope.
I don't give a freshman as fuck.
I just don't smell.
And then I'm like,
light a candle.
That's beautiful.
Beautiful.
That's what you need is a bathroom with
a door that faces out.
The worst is when you go over a girl's
house and you go to use your bathroom
and you smell matches.
Oh yeah.
Oh No.
She was lightened.
This motherfucker up tall.
You're thinking about burdening her off
fumes.
Yeah,
the stinky.
But thinking about her math.
You ever get to a girl's place and then
you feel the gurgles and you're like,
read one.
I could.
I've had that before.
I was dating a girl once.
She had ferocious diarrhea.
Ferocious.
So she was in regular time.
So she went to the bathroom and she just
turned on the shower and she turns on
both things on the sink.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And just see what she tried to drown it
out.
I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
I was very young at the time.
It didn't understand what was super
confused.
The fuck is going on in there.
I had,
I had once in college where I was at
this girl's place and she was just like,
Hey,
it's game on,
like go for it,
right?
Like I have to take and I could feel
that it was a diarrhea,
explosive diarrhea shit.
And I also realized there was no way to
do it that,
that it would just be a black toilet and
there's no way I could cover.
So you know what I did?
I went back to my place,
I was like,
I'll,
I'll see you some other time or
whatever.
And the next day her friends like,
you're like the fucking,
like they gave me credit,
let that guy that I was a good because
they were like,
you're awesome.
And I was like,
no,
I had to take my girls because they're
not getting fucked and they don't want
their friend to get fucked.
Right.
So they used reverse psychology on you.
You're an amazing guy.
I got an amazing guy.
Credit help you wait forever.
A cycle that you left out.
Even when you get married,
tell her,
get married to have sex after you're
married.
Never.
It's not about that.
It's about real love.
If I had had bows that were intact,
it would have been a different story
that night.
But bowels.
Bowels.
Yeah.
There's a time when you know that it's
in the sensitivity of your inner asshole
region.
Amazing.
It is.
It knows.
Especially when you go to seep out a
Fart,
right?
When you're about to cut a fart and then
also the alarms start going off.
You're like,
oh no.
Oh yeah.
Oh No,
you've got to clamp shot.
You're like,
Jesus,
what is this?
We were having this debate yesterday
about why are they sometimes hot,
like why is it hot and then why does.
Why do you know that hot is going to
smell bad?
Spicy food bro is the.
But is that what it is?
Solely?
I don't know.
I was telling you guys at one time my
freshman year,
I didn't take your ship for a week and a
half.
I was addicted.
This fake
to how long is that?
I was in when I was five.
I played freshman ball and we were
playing paterson eastside.
Wait,
just a jungle over school.
Like you got to be careful when you're
going there and we went there to play
the Christmas tournament.
Well,
what kind of ball are we talking right
now?
Basketball and I hadn't taken a shift
for like 10 days.
I was something.
I took acid,
something fucked my thought until nobody
in those days I was really scared of
doctors and I wouldn't say shit to
nobody.
Way Home.
We got on the bus and while we will
wait,
their stomach started hurting and I
said,
Jesus Christ,
I don't know if I'm going to shit myself
a Fart,
but let me just take a chance.
Good move.
And I blew this far.
Joe Rogan.
That was so bad,
right?
We want a bus and people started
running.
You know the school buses.
People started running into the wind
goes right to swing down the bus
windows,
but here's what it gets better.
I father again,
teachers would go,
oh my God,
he's changing flavors,
but what's the worst thing was the
cheerleaders are crying.
That's how bad they were sitting in
front of the bus going to.
The teachers yelled,
Oh my God,
he's changing.
That's how bad parts,
next tee shirt.
He's changing bus.
I'll never forget looking at the
cheerleaders were like,
Oh my God,
we've never smelled like this.
Big fight was fucking God awful.
I wrote a blog about one enjoys farts
wants because I don't have plain.
Yes.
I think I read.
That's called happy pills and it was.
I was thinking about.
I was,
I was looking at this ad,
take this.
I was looking at this ad for
antidepressants,
some girl,
a field of wheat and shit.
You know those,
those ads and a good.
I was just thinking about like,
like what?
You know,
what depresses people and how crazy
pills are and how great.
Oh,
it's still up there.
You can still find it.
Anyway,
at the end of this is really like me.
We're both,
both of us are barbecued.
I don't know what the fuck.
What do we add?
Some sort of edibles in the beginning.
Lolly pops way in the beginning of
we were crucified.
Oregon was asleep.
Yeah,
he was going in and out,
but he wrote on the blog and I don't
even have to look at the farm.
Was strong.
He's lucky I fought it because it was a
lot better than the Antonio banderas
movie he was watching something to do is
on Antonio banderas moving in.
I don't remember what it was,
what it was,
but I do remember the lady behind you.
I will never forget hearing her over the
ear phones.
Yeah,
I hear.
Oh my God,
there it is.
Over the salad in my ipod.
I hear a woman in the row behind us cry
out.
Oh my God.
I look over at show and he smiles.
There's your fucking happy pill right
there.
That's your right.
Antonio banderas it says.
Oh,
what was it?
Oh yeah.
Teaching underprivileged youth.
How to salsa.
Oh,
that's what I was watching.
I was watching a terrible move.
Terrible.
We both were and Joey farted.
The fart of all.
Do you remember?
By the way,
the seat.
You haven't had those parts where you
actually feel your leg was jazz.
When you're in a plane and it's going to
go down,
what's the button you push?
Your seat was seat belted into your
waist.
My God,
it was terrible,
but another time I fought.
I used to,
I used to take the number one bus from
Jersey City to the high school and we
were on the bus one morning kids and
there was a guy reading a paper,
I can live to be 100 and never forget
this reading the daily news and he had a
connector of drool from his lift,
the Daily News,
and it was a puddle.
He was on heroin.
They would go to Jersey City in those
days and get Methadone so they would
take the bus up north with us.
So I'm sitting there,
he's passed the fuck out and the drool
is connected to the daily news and this
guy to be just six inches of public.
This guy's been passed out for 20
minutes.
I point my ass at him.
I'm not sitting behind them.
I'm sitting across from them and I lift
up my hips a little bit.
Kept my ass or just point that even if
it wasn't pointed at him,
he would ricochet off the chair and go
straight and through his mouth.
Like he's sitting there and I let a fart
go out.
Oh,
I could live to be 80.
He lifted his eyes like he went like
this first,
like,
man,
who the fuck?
He goes,
it smells like something.
Went up some of these as and died and me
and my little buddies were like,
what?
The center will fucking giggling.
He like,
I should beat the fuck out of my.
Oh my God.
Fantastic.
This is why I hate people.
This is why I hate when I read.
Give me a second.
This is the reason why I ain't read
posts from people going,
are you singing tonight as blue comedy
will come down to the standard feeder in
Friday night and listened to intelligent
comedy,
fought provoking comedy,
and then I think about it,
how many times I'm 54 years old and at
night I got a sleep apnea machine on and
there's a little needle in the sleep
apnea machine because the hall was
punches and into your fucking mouth.
So there's an escape valve that's the
size of a needle.
You know how many nights I will sit
there and be half asleep and I'll need
the fart and I'll wake up just to see if
I could smell the fucking fart.
Come through that whole you?
Yes.
If it comes through,
it's a tremendous fault.
I just wake up my wife like I go on it.
You got it.
Have it.
Like it's that good.
I'm 54 years old.
That always makes me laptops to Gore.
People say to me like,
I love thought provoking collie dog.
If it makes you laugh.
It's comedy.
Stop with the fucking,
you know,
you almost hospitalized me one time from
laughing so hard.
Like,
I don't know if you remember this.
I'm serious.
I don't even know if I could tell it.
It was.
It was backstage.
It was backstage at his show.
We were somewhere and you were like,
how's the wife?
You and I go,
you go where she.
And I said,
I said some city in Tennessee,
maybe Knoxville or Nashville,
and you go Nashville 90 six and you
started the story about working the club
and you're like,
I just riffed in between shows some
crazy shit.
Come chick who's talking?
There was eight people,
there was 20 people for the first show,
Knoxville.
It was a comedy zone show.
I have booked it.
Knoxville's a great little fucking town,
like a cute little Tennessee town does
it?
It's like hip,
it's,
you know,
like a college town.
So I get down Friday night,
Joe Rogan,
I'm headlining,
I got 38 minutes,
I just moved to La and I signed with
creative management and they booked
those wrongs.
So booking me on as Atlanta.
I was just dying.
Slowed that.
So what they did was they put me in one
nighters that paid like two 75 and nine.
They weren't bad.
Tennessee,
you know,
and we go to Knoxville for two nights
and I go in there and you know me,
I'm fucking crazy.
First night I go in there to Friday
night,
there's 20 people for the first show and
there's a girl,
Joe Rogan that's a 12 with a guy that's
a four.
Okay.
And it's her birthday,
you know,
meanwhile through it,
she just turned 21.
It's a birthday.
Okay,
happy what's going on here,
you know,
because once you start hearing noise you
have to react to it as a comment and you
go,
what's going on?
And he was 21.
I said,
you're very beautiful.
And then she just went and ran with it
and started talking about how her
husband pimps are out.
He would have fights on and for 20 bucks
you could fuck her in the back room
twice.
Fights were on whatever.
I don't know that on Fridays he would
bring it to the construction truck,
a truck with her to the construction
site and put a mattress in the back and
at lunchtime he will let her friends and
she's telling me this.
It's like she's 12 and people like just
holding their breasts,
like what is going on here?
This girl is beautiful and this retarded
just pimping up.
So in between shows,
I go upstairs to do a line of smoke,
a joint or whatever the fuck I'm doing.
When I come back I see her by herself.
When we start talking to them about
what's going on,
oh my God,
I had such a great time.
I go,
what's that stuff?
True?
And she goes,
yeah,
I go show me the monkey.
And she me in the woman's bathroom
pulled down her pants.
The girl had a monkey that was spotless.
She didn't nearly stunk.
I ate it.
I find that some.
And then she sucked my Dick.
That was it.
I went back to my room.
I didn't think nothing of it.
I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
I go back for the second show that AP.
But by the time I got back for the
second show,
Joe Rogan,
she's sitting in the back,
she's doing,
she's looking at me like this.
She's fucked up and 10 minutes into my
spot set because I was headlining.
She starts going,
I sucked the Comedians Dick Tonight.
And I was like,
what are you talking about?
And she's like,
I suck this Dick.
And he came in my mouth,
he's like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
The cops had to hold him back and he's
like,
I want my $40.
That's all he wanted.
He didn't care his wife Suck my dick at
this comedy bedroom.
Oh my God.
When the cops came,
he kept saying,
man,
somebody is going to get hurt if I don't
have my $40.
That's a 40 hour blow job.
Did you come in her mouth?
Because if I wouldn't have come,
it would have been late 20.
Oh he cared about was the $40.
So he told me that backstage at your
show.
And I fucking started hyperventilating.
$40 for his wife.
This is the world of comedy,
Ladies and Gentlemen,
this is the world of crazy fucking
comedy.
Jesus.
I think that's crazy why she's crying.
Some of the hugging his wife and said,
you know,
no,
he didn't care.
He just wanted the $40 with a blow job.
I didn't give it to them.
It's got rules.
You've got to give him that.
He's got like a line in the sand.
Mrs Got.
He's got 40 fucking crazy animal when
you sit at home at night and you think
about all the shit we were seeing,
we were learning a lot.
I don't think I've ever laughed as hard.
Well,
that's probably second time right there
on that road.
We do a lot of things.
You want a lot of things about human
beings.
You.
One of the things about individual,
you learn some grabbing my American
home.
It's uh,
uh,
armed forces place in Idaho.
It's part of the triple rock.
This was,
I walked in and I had to go meet,
do a sound check her,
but he kept looking at me going,
hi,
how are you?
Have you met sandy yet?
And I go,
no.
And they go and they can walk away.
You ever see a movie with Eddie Murphy
when he with Boomerang,
when he goes to the black chicks out
said to 80 and the Butler keeps
laughing.
Remember the Butler would go.
She wants to see in the kitchen.
He would go because she knew he was
gonna.
She was gonna rape him.
So every time somebody will refer to
Shirley,
they go,
have you met Shirley?
And you go,
no.
And they go,
oh,
and they'd walk away with Shirley,
wherever the capital that base was the
head of the base.
She was his wife.
And if a band came to town or a comedian
came to town,
she blue.
That's it.
That was the rule.
Like he and he would sit out there with
his fucking military armed with all his
shit and class and she'd be in the back
color mink because the whole band,
I mean this is crazy.
So I didn't know about this.
She came over and started talking to me
and then she started telling all your
Cuban.
I dated to Cuba one time.
He was such a big thick.
You have a big thing.
I mean it was that white glove.
It was quick.
Like she just gets to it.
She's like 15.
I was maybe like 31.
She was maybe 50 and she just dropped
behind the curtain,
took the hammer out.
I'm sitting there minding my own
business and all of a sudden somebody
comes yelling for Shirley,
Shirley,
Shirley.
Now usually,
surely we get up and stop sucking your
Dick.
Not Surely.
She moved her knees like I had neon
belly.
Belly.
He's supposed to move this way.
That's what she did with a nice.
She kept sucking and just kept moving
this way.
She.
I tried to take it out of her mouth.
She wouldn't let it.
She's like,
no,
no.
She,
she wouldn't stop until I met Shirley
out here and this is crazy shit.
I can't.
I'm overstimulated.
I feel like I feel like I need
psychiatric treatment right now.
We just finished that fucking drink.
My main greatest thing anyone's ever
said that is the best word mean kid
juice.
But boy it's minky.
Ah,
but when they say they cut it short,
what is the word?
What does it mean?
Get me,
suck my Dick.
Mika.
In the Sukkah.
Right.
Okay.
You know,
it's so weird how the morning.
This is Italian Sicilian.
Really?
So the deeper you go down to boot,
the more.
Is it closer to Spain or is it farther
from spraying?
The closer it Lee is from Spain.
When people from that area speak
Italian,
I don't care how fast they're talking,
they can't put the wool over me because
I can pick up every four words.
Right.
So Sicilian say Sukkah what's sucking
Spanish?
Trooper.
You're in the neighborhood,
right?
So when they say it's like,
you know what,
what are you gonna do today?
I'm going to go and get my Minka suck.
But sue,
I mean because just the short second
shirt of this show.
So on me.
Sure.
And then you got minka juice comes at
you where you want it.
Cheers.
When you,
when you hear those Latin languages like
Spanish and you hear a Italian,
like those languages seem to like feel
like a let's have fun language.
You know,
everything has got a thing to it.
It's kind of a rhythm.
There's a way to talk.
It is fun.
Yeah.
Fun to listen to.
Especially not really knowing anything
about what they're saying.
I can pick up like one out of 100 words
maybe.
Right?
Yeah.
And so I hear them talking and I'm like,
well,
when bitcoin was in,
but it's.
So for me it's almost just like hearing
the rhythm of them talking.
Yeah.
It's like a fun sort of a smooth relax,
but I get you an express or talk to you
and it's very hard when other gestures,
hand gestures.
Yeah.
You can always tell when a Latin person
like across a room.
Yeah.
Just by their hand gestures and they
start,
you know,
glad to see me les to see me like this.
Just hearing how long did it take you?
How long do you think it takes you for
you?
Just to get the book.
If you're in France for a week?
Yeah.
Like it takes you three days just to get
the like I'm not going to learn French
and three days,
but let's take you three days to get the
Jif.
I wonder like French,
like if they come up to you and ask you
what you want from the menu.
Like after you go to nine restaurants,
three days he had a little something.
Yeah.
You get.
Especially if you have like a Latin root
too though,
you know,
like you're comfortable with it.
Does it ever bother you when you hear
stories about Americans going to like
Paris and like,
uh,
the Persians thinking the Americans were
Dicks,
the Americans like acting like assholes
to people from Paris.
Like what is that?
Like?
How did that whole room or get started?
The loud American.
Yeah.
Had that whole like us versus Paris
thing.
You remember when they wouldn't call
things French fries that were calling
freedom fries.
Bushier,
right.
Do you remember that?
Yeah,
like freedom fries.
It's always like the French,
you know,
like there's always,
there's always some weird like right
wing punchline about the French.
How much interaction do you.
I think at point for me it's inherited
or.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
I think it's every country.
Remember that episode of the Sopranos?
Women with daily chef.
Can I get some red shorts?
He's like,
I want a red sauce.
Marinara,
and the guy looked at the other guy.
He goes,
if you think these Germans a class list,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
look at this guy here.
He's like,
they all have.
Every country must have something
towards.
Yeah.
I hear that.
We're hated across the world,
but then one person like you traveling,
you go know pro people were very nice.
They are nice.
If you are nice and I think that's
universal.
People are Nice if you're nice.
Yeah,
pretty powerful that people appreciate
it pretty much everywhere.
People are Nice.
If you're nice,
you know,
and and the way you are changes the way
they are,
you know,
like if you run into someone and maybe
they're a little bit defensive but
you're openly friendly,
a lot of times the relaxed that whereas
if you run into someone in their sort of
defensive and you're aggressive with
them,
then it ramps up and the whole thing
becomes like some sort of a weird ego
disaster st person,
different person interacting with them
saying the same words.
It's just the whole thing about people
and the way we talk to each other.
Yeah,
because we're,
it's a,
there's no one person responsible for an
argument,
you know,
most of the time it comes from both
sides and how you interact with people.
Even if you feel like you did nothing
wrong.
It's a lot of times,
like a big part of how the conversation
started shaping itself.
People don't want to.
Everybody wants everything to be black
or white,
right?
It's either like if you got an argument
with the dude,
it's his fault or it's your fault,
but it could easily be both.
Can easily be like just a mismanaged
situation.
You know,
you might have been coming there because
there might've been some fucking problem
that they were supposed to fix on your
car and they didn't and you know,
you are in your car headed to the comedy
store and you're like this mother fucker
and the light starts going on again.
Like God damn it and you get there.
You're already a little bit ramped up
and you run into someone and then you're
already coming at them at like a six and
if you get an interaction with them
about like,
hey man,
anything I can get in front of you,
I got to go some where you're like,
fuck you man.
Right?
That could happen.
Totally does.
You don't know.
That's why I've always learned the very
important lesson in life.
You don't know what that guy's going
through it today.
No one does.
Right before you hit her members,
before you give that dirty guy,
it's the hardest thing to cut them off.
Yeah.
You don't know if his wife just left.
The kid just told him she was a lesbian.
You know,
this is all of a sudden he's got a
girlfriend.
He goes,
have a fucking gun car.
You don't know what somebody is going
through.
Right?
You have no idea what time that mind
coming up to you.
You know?
One of the most genius thing is I ever
heard was
that a great Carlo Gambino.
Never answered his own door.
He always had his wife answered the door
because no matter how mad a mobster came
over,
no matter how,
like he just got off the phone with this
fucking guy and he won't give me 10
kilos.
Carlos' going to resume this no matter
how mad I came into the house,
his wife would stop you,
make you sit down and give you an
express on giving you a score and talk
to you.
So by the time you got into Carlo,
you were slowed down.
He was very smart that way.
That's beautiful because he always,
his wife was like,
everybody's mom,
one of those ladies that you'll go ahead
and come in and get me.
So that's why it's not good for
everybody.
If men get together for long periods of
time,
I think that I think that people should.
Anybody who's involved with customer
service should take some type of
something to let to calm people down.
Like people who work at an airport,
you know,
there's got to be a system out of slow
somebody down.
It's a brilliant system.
Having a wife that like a very nice
person that sits you down and you
realize like,
listen,
this is what's important in this kind of
friendship here.
Like half of the issues that people get
into.
It's a perspective issue.
It's like,
like especially if you're like a monster
and he thinks so much fucking you over
and you're like,
oh,
you know,
where's my fucking money?
And you sit down,
like come on.
Perspective issue.
Yeah.
It's most of what it is like how are you
looking at your relationship?
Are you trying to fuck this person over
here trying to work together in harmony?
If you're just trying to work together
in harmony,
I bet it'll work out.
We all travel.
We ever have a bad travel day and we get
to a hotel and we'll fucking furious
with that little lady at the counter
made us laugh and for sure about what
just happened.
True.
And should we even do something that
will change your whole outlook for the
day?
Like she'll go,
oh by the way,
I know you were delayed.
We told the kitchen to save your
spaghetti and meatballs and you're like,
you bad motherfucker.
You Wow.
You know?
So that's.
I liked it when that happens.
I love when I'm furious and like walk
into a hotel and somebody slows me down
and talks to me and it's really cool
when people have that.
That's a gift by the way,
to actually slow somebody down and be
able to touch him and go,
hey man,
it's going to be fun and coming up.
Let me take it to the track them.
If you have a business,
you have a customer service
representative,
someone who meets people at the door and
that person has an amazing personality.
That shit is worth a lot of money.
Oh yeah.
I can't coach it.
You can't train whether it's a guy or a
girl and I've met him on both sides.
You know,
you meet people that work in a certain
place where you look forward to going
back to that place to saying hi to that
guy because that guy is just super cool.
You're like,
what's up?
What's up man?
And like you've made like legitimate
friendship with this person and that's
possible too.
You know,
this idea that we all have to be
constantly at odds with each other and I
think even like security people,
like when I see when I'm in a restaurant
or a bar or a sporting event and I see a
security guy is what's that word is
dissolve the situation without throwing
a punch.
Especially when a person a good one,
especially when a person's drunk.
Listen,
I can talk to you when you're sober.
Once you got four cocktails on the,
I'm going to talk to you once.
Some of my patients lead,
well,
it's Donald,
you know it's fucking dark,
but there are some people who stay calm
and they go,
we know man,
let's just take a walk over here and
talk about it and you fall for it.
Next thing you know,
you're out,
Brian.
No matter if your girlfriends with some
other guy,
you know,
they come rushing into a bar and people
were tremendous at that.
That's a great gift.
You know who can do that shit?
Big John Mccarthy,
big John McCarthy.
Who's the best at like separating shit
when shit goes sideways and the octagon,
isn't he an ex police officer and he's a
giant because the giant.
I mean he's a big dude.
He's a black belt in Jujitsu and when,
when shit gets weird inside the octagon,
the cop and hip comes out.
People if there's some chaos and some
crazy shit,
he puts out fucking halt to that no
more.
Yeah,
those guys are important,
man.
It's important to have people like that.
Now that is a skill though is it's a
giant skill.
It also be a good guy,
which he also is like,
like big John McCarthy's a hell of a
human,
by the way.
Formally congrats on a thousand men.
That's really awesome.
Listen,
amazing party started.
Hey guys.
It's really incredible,
man.
It's probably more right.
I think it's like a hundred and 43 or
something.
Probably real riddick.
There's a bunch of other named ones.
Fight companions,
fight breakdowns.
That would never,
ever dream when you started doing these
meaning either they would have the
impact that they have.
Let's just keep that shit known.
Void.
Fucking saying like people want to hear
this.
I remember him calling me up to the room
with me yelling at Joe and like fucking
crazy fuckers home on a Friday night.
Thirteen year old is.
Take that off.
Take that shit off when I'm smoking pot.
We were in the green room at the
peninsula.
No,
no carbs.
No.
This was somewhere else.
This is doing a podcast.
Meet him in red bank.
One of the first podcast we did was off
this thing called Justin Dot TV.
Justin TV and we didn't agree and we did
them back when there were cellular
modems,
so he'd be streaming like there wasn't
like a lot of Wifi back then,
so we'd be streaming from a cell phone
hookup.
Yeah,
it was terrible.
Like real pixilated stuff.
But we were like,
this could be fucking weird and have
people like watch us get ready in the
green room talking to the camera.
We're just can be bizarre.
So we decided to do a few of those,
but Joe,
he was like,
get this fucking thing away from me.
But that was,
that was the different Joey Diaz back
then,
you know,
you were still uncomfortable.
You know,
it was funny with that.
That was the thing that set you free to
let people know who you are.
At the beginning when he was like,
hey dude,
weren't you also like,
what the fuck are you doing?
No,
no,
no.
I was like,
are you like a bird collar kind of guy
or something like,
I thought it was like one of those
weird.
You know what I mean?
Things that people do though.
It was like a bird call.
Are we talking about man,
he was onto it.
He would be on there at night and I just
didn't like it.
I didn't know,
but then Dane Cook became a megastar
would my space and everybody in that
mother went on.
That was before me,
but they were not cook.
They was doing.
They just thought by going on my space
and going,
I got free tickets tonight.
Yeah,
that.
That was gonna work.
They ain't cook.
Was communicating with them.
True and people would see the
communication and go,
wow,
we can have live interaction,
blah,
blah.
Dane was doing that way before me.
He was doing that on my space and my
2002 or something like that.
Right.
Wasn't it by the way?
Early on.
Yeah.
What about in 2003?
We'll check the lineup.
Will check the old calendars.
We did the fourth of July weekend in
Nirvana and I'll never forget that.
I said to you,
do you have radio?
And you go,
I have no radio.
I'm a little panicked and that Thursday
when we got down to the whole weekend
was so good and that's what I said,
Joe Rogan's onto something with that
fucking computer,
like,
fuck this shit,
because my philosophy was that computer.
Do you think Richard Pryor would go home
before the morning coked up and get on
fucking facebook.
That was my thing at that time,
like sunglasses,
fucking thing,
that fucking Richard Price and they go
home and get on on my space.
So I was exposed it,
but once I saw five sold out shows and
Irvine,
the older vine when it was known that if
you didn't do radio,
nobody's going to show up there.
And that was it.
That was it.
To me,
that was maybe a believer that there's
something there.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
The,
uh,
the range of people that come up to me
about your show,
you know,
like the,
like all types of fucking pilots,
a fighter I've had like amateur
fighters,
professional fighters,
the range of people that are interested
in your show,
you know what I mean?
It's a really wide range of people.
It's fascinating.
Like it's really reached a lot of
people.
Man.
I was freaking me out,
man.
I was in burbank the other day.
Okay,
so you got a haircut?
We could go.
All right.
You don't make the.
I had,
I went to Jujitsu and had a half hour to
kill.
So before they had cut,
I just smoked a joint.
I was in my car on Magnolia Boulevard up
the block from Porto's,
which is fucking back.
And I opened up the sunroof and I just
started smoking a joint before they had
cut and I put a piece of gum in my mouth
and I actually walked through the
crosswalk to walk across the street and
there was a lady holding a kid with
another one in the thing and she looked
at me and when she looked at me and go,
fuck,
this lady smells me.
You know when you,
when you don't have a child,
you don't give a fuck about refund.
But when you have a child and you see a
mom with a child,
you feel kind of fucking sorry man.
I didn't say it until she looked at me
and she goes,
oh my God,
with the kid in her thing and with the
Stroller,
she looked at me,
she goes,
blue cheese with your fucking mother.
I loved it.
I'm from Buffalo.
I looked at her and she just kept
walking,
but it was like the type of woman that
wouldn't say that to me with the kid
ended up pushing.
She goes,
blue cheese with wings and go,
fuck your mother.
I love you.
And She just kept walking.
I was like,
oh my God.
Amazing man.
What?
What about?
I went to Sacramento and families with
kids.
It's fucking crazy,
but the realm of the people,
why they come up to you and Tsa?
Don't forget about Tsa,
Tsa,
but the realm of people and the reasons
why.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what the actual,
which always killed me.
Like I've been around for 20 years and
what made you come to my show is I
totally shit about.
I told the story about taking a shit in
somebody's back yard.
I loved it.
We laughed like you.
You're like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
That's what,
you know when somebody comes up to me,
it's always they came to a show for
something different.
I said on here.
Yeah,
you know,
that's really weird.
It's amazing.
And the,
like you said,
the contrast.
It's not just a six foot guy.
No,
it's everything.
Steroid guy.
It's a mom with a baby in a stroller.
I was saying I have people that so want
me to give you things.
It's so annoying.
They're like,
because they always start with like
trying to flatter me and like try and
they're like,
dude,
I think you're fucking hilarious.
I go,
thanks man.
I love your shit.
I listen to it.
I listened to on the way to work every
day and I'm like,
oh,
thanks a lot.
And they're like,
yeah man,
it's so funny.
Like I love this bit and that bit and
I'll be like,
it's very nice you man.
Thank you very much.
Like,
and I listened to your podcast and I
fucking love it.
It's so fucking funny.
I'm like,
thank you.
And then they're like,
hey,
will you give this to Joe?
That's their,
their whole thing like did you think
because you told me all those
compliments,
I'm going to be your messenger and
they'd be like,
no,
I mean,
just like if you could give it to them.
Okay,
sure.
I get this request every other week.
What kind of weird shit?
I tell always fucking packages and
envelopes.
I don't open.
The men could.
Yeah.
No,
they go right.
I tell them to send them directly to you
and like the cup he gave to him and tell
him to do that.
He gave me two cups.
I gave one to Alberto and I gave one to
you.
This is a highly ineffective way to
communicate with people.
I sending them shit,
you know,
people think that I want to have shit in
my car.
Like he gives us the time,
like I'm going to have this in my
fucking car.
I got the newest latest Bong.
It's totally different than it is a
bong.
First of all,
you can drop it out of an airplane.
It will not break.
It's military grade,
bro.
This is the bog.
The bog dwindled bongs.
The catastrophe apocalypto you've had
this pitch ended the world bomb,
Bro.
This bond is made out of the same shit
that Wolverine's claws.
There's a closet in my office,
guy slide open and I cannot tell you.
I must have a 300 black tee shirts from
different bands and shit and I got
every.
I mean look at me.
I got every protein,
powder,
fuel and energy thing that you can come
and get me.
I got more geese.
Most Jujitsu schools.
Yeah.
That's how many gies a given to me.
Mailed to me.
I have to mail them back.
My wife says,
I seen one more fucking.
I will throw that shit out.
It's just amazing albums because people
know I like.
I come home with vinyl every fucking
week.
Really?
Some of it is fucking atrocious,
but some of it is fantastic.
I listened to everything you do.
You have a hard time checking out old
shit.
I feel bad for people.
I understand that they've worked for it
and I understand that they went out of
their way for it,
but if I haven't seen Duncan in six
months and I got a bullish candle,
it goes in the garbage.
Like once Dunkin moved to New York,
I grew all Duncan's shit.
Only saved mushrooms.
Mvma for already come up to me and get
me heavy drugs for like I will bring it
back on the plane for rob because he's
my brother.
Oh,
you know what they come and get some guy
gave about a month ago gave me a book
about Stars and Oh Jesus.
When I looked,
he was the author.
Like if that gets told everyone.
That guy gave me that book and I showed
it to you,
like how to be a real man.
One of his rules was be 40.
That'd be a real man.
He was just like,
we went over it on your podcast,
man,
that guy for a long time.
He gave that to like a bunch of us.
We have Hong Kong and he was like,
here's this book.
I'd rather let me look at it as him on
the cover and it's all glossy and he's
in.
He's looking off to the side and that
was when I first did your podcasts.
He was the first time I did it.
Yeah.
That was how many years ago that.
That was probably when we started at
seven years ago.
It was probably five years ago.
Yeah.
I do get a lot of Nice shit though.
Oh yeah.
I do get a lot of new.
I'm talking about when people might have
with the studio who made that thing.
A kid in Cleveland thing is good.
Uh,
I got,
I get great books sent to me.
I mean,
phenomenal money books.
I'm reading one right now.
That is the creepiest thing.
The three lives with Jimmy page from
led.
Jump on that motherfucker traveled with
a 14 year old girl,
Bro.
Never got charged with statutory rape.
Really just traveled with him for years.
He's just a runaway on the tour,
on the tour,
like fucking crazy.
He taught me.
Is that true?
You know,
talking about his house and fucking,
uh,
in uh,
where he lived.
He bought it from Alice,
took it,
was Alex to Crowley's all house,
a 24 karat warlock.
He was,
he lived in his house and you know,
for some people it was like a way to
sell records.
Not for those,
for those four were onto something
magical,
you know,
they were magical mine albums,
but this book kind of like,
I got to put it down for two days at a
time sometimes.
Really?
Yeah.
He's a fucking nut.
That's what's called the three live
looking.
The 10 wildest led Zeppelin led jazz
shit.
Scroll this shit down.
Joe Rogan.
He did a 14 year old.
Crazy man.
The truth Mannix was amazing.
Just 14 when she met page paige page.
Did what he could to keep the
relationship hidden.
Oh,
that's true.
That's crazy.
Wow.
That's weird.
He was crazy when they shoved the
little.
What they've shoveled after a baby shark
of the schicks pussy was so weird,
man.
Like you could.
You could do that back then,
right?
Like you could do weird shit back then.
Yeah.
It makes you stop and think like what
that is.
It's like the,
just the beginning of the information
age,
right.
Newspapers regularly distributed
television shows on the news.
All that stuff was only like a few
decades old when the sixties and the
seventies rolled around.
I mean,
you really think about the timeline
there.
It's really kind of fascinating.
Do you ever think about the jump from in
technology from like,
you know,
like you know how it sites that there
was no us weekly there.
Right?
Right.
So things kind of advance and now
everything's monitored and now for
instance,
you can record a phone call.
Right?
Which is like would be a difficult thing
to do back then.
Or you can have a recorder running on
you.
Do you ever think about how that lack,
you know,
the privacy goes away and how to,
to to some degree,
we can't even conceive of it right now,
but how easy it will be to record
everything at some point.
Like how it'll,
you know,
we joked like it's in
your watch or it's in your glasses,
but it will be like you'll walk out of
every conversation and there'll be some,
some form to document it.
Yeah,
it'd be a total loss.
So there's gonna be,
there's gonna be some changes.
I don't necessarily agree are done.
I'm not convinced I should say not
agree.
I'm not convinced that they're going to
be bad to do that.
Yeah,
I,
I just,
I wonder like what,
what,
what's gained through this kind of
privacy now I'm not talking about like
privacy,
like corporations or the government
being able to look into your life.
I'm talking about we might get to a
position as human beings within our
lifetime where everybody looks into
everything about everybody.
Everything,
right?
Finances your day to day life sexually
here,
seeing you everywhere you go,
no matter what you do.
Like what we could get to a position
where there's no disconnection from any
of us,
but we're all connected to each other.
If this keeps going the way it goes.
Right.
So it used to be everybody lived far
apart and you know,
you have to ride a horse to get to the
friend,
say hi and talk to them and hopefully
he's still alive when he came back the
next day know.
But there was no communication.
Then it got two phone calls it in as as
things have ramped up and now it's in
your phone and now your phone's in your
watch and now your watch can tell you
who's calling you and you can.
You can look at your phone and you see
the person start track type shit already
happening,
right?
Yeah,
and it's getting deeper and deeper and
deeper.
People are streaming live streaming live
streaming facebook.
No matter what they do all day.
There's a slew of people paying video
games,
live streaming.
People are tuning in,
watching other people play video games.
I mean we're getting deeper and deeper
into this technological rabbit hole
where it becomes embedded in your life
in a way that was unimaginable before it
was introduced.
Same thing as cell phones before cell
phones were introduced.
Who would have ever believed,
if you told them that you were going to
get to a point in human history where it
is totally common to see people staring
at electronic screens while they're all
sitting together at a dinner table,
that they could be five people sitting
around and they not even talking to each
other.
They're just staring at this electronic
screen and that screen is compelling.
You know it.
I know it.
I get drawn to it.
You get drawn to it.
When that was,
man might be some crazy news.
Let me check Google real quick.
You never know.
You never know what weird shit has been
happening in the world and you get
sucked into this.
This thing is becoming a part of your
life in a weird way that nobody
anticipated.
If it keeps going in the direction that
it's going,
it's going to get weirder in a way we
never anticipated before where it's not
going to be just as simple as put your
phone down and go outside.
It's going to be your phone's a part of
you.
It's going to happen.
Your phone's almost a part of you.
Now,
if you have to have it,
like I connected to this
goddamn thing more than I touched my
dog,
right?
Total.
I love my dog,
but I touched that thing more than I'd
touch my dog.
It's weird.
You want to protect.
It's not a pardon me man.
I could just put it right there right
there.
Lenses right there.
Don't go anywhere.
I got you right here.
That's basically a part of me.
It's basically a part of me.
How long before I let them open me up?
Still means there's a spot in my armpit.
I don't mean use those little.
There's a great short about that.
There's a great short film about.
Yes.
What's it called?
I don't.
I don't remember the name of it,
but it ends up like under the guise skin
out.
It's going to happen.
It's really cool.
I wish to stay away from this fucking
thing.
I tradjenta a different room at night.
You know the Ipad I bought the right.
No fucking facebook.
Twitter or not that.
Neil Brandon rush on an IPAD.
I bought an IPAD.
Do you have like one of those little
keyboard things you connect to a case
like that bro?
It's changed my life.
I used to have three hours of just shit.
Time of day that it's not enough to work
out.
So what are you writing notes?
Use the notes program.
What do you.
Yeah,
I just write and fucking notes and if I
don't like the joke that night I can go
back and add the tag.
You know what's real good.
If you ever tried evernote,
evernote is real good.
It allows you to use pictures,
all kinds of different things in black
out,
everything else.
Um,
no,
that's a different thing.
That's a right room.
But ever note,
uh,
you,
if you,
uh,
write things like the things you want to
remember maybe before sets,
you can write them down in evernote and
then sync them from your ipad to your
phone and back and forth.
It's really good.
It's one that I use.
I just got this ipad pro for three weeks
ago and it's changed my life.
Yeah,
that's,
it changed my life.
I could give a fuck about twitter,
facebook hot,
nothing.
When I go to that coffee shop,
the right,
it's just that program.
I have everything else in there,
but I haven't even program.
I have the apps that I got my fitness
plan and they're like a bjj training
adrenaline and that's it.
You know what I said about the Internet,
man,
I think about the Internet,
like I think about foods that are sweet,
like you can have them as long as you
don't have too much,
too much,
don't get crazy.
That's how I feel about even going
online.
I think we're.
We're,
we're,
we're getting to this weird point where
we're just relinquishing our,
our consciousness to this machine,
relinquishing our consciousness
connection that we all enjoy.
It's not a consciousness.
It's the consciousness.
We're all sharing about a certain topic.
We all have to interject on what we
think about Charlottesville or about
trump and stuff like that.
These days you get on facebook and
twitter and you're fucking sad.
You get sad.
You get sad for people.
Okay.
I make it a habit.
Friday,
Saturday,
and Sundays.
No reason to be on the Internet.
You have to stay away from it.
There's no reason that the shows are
sold out.
Your family's at home.
What?
What are you only go there?
This is my.
This is my cheeseburger.
Yeah.
I give a fuck.
So on the weekends I don't touch it.
I forced myself,
don't touch it for what?
You have to have a life,
man.
Yeah,
we are.
We are forgetting that there's a life.
You ever go to a park and look at these
fucking parents looking at their phones.
You call it a park where your kid don't
you?
Yeah.
I don't take my phone out of the car.
The park.
There's no recall.
You,
your manager tell you they changed your
spot at the store from 10,
15 to 10:30.
If you're with your kid and your wife,
you don't need your phone.
You really don't show.
You got to get into floating man.
How come you home float?
Because I smoked pot and I think of this
shit on my own.
Yeah,
but it's different.
That's why it's not.
It's not what you're thinking.
I can anxieties.
Yeah,
but you'll be fine.
Becky works at the place in Pasadena and
we've been talking about a lot about it.
I'm really scared about these little
dabs of anxiety that I get from time to
time.
You'll be fine.
It's good for your health.
No.
I know it's good for my health,
but when I go get good blood with your
dad to go blood,
no problem.
Wait,
does weed make you more anxious or less
anxious and smoothing into out.
Okay.
So then when it comes to certain things
I have to see a window.
Like it's really weird and right now
there's not a window in it but I see
that fucking door.
Like when I walk up the steps at the
original room and I get anxiety when a
comics on stage.
It could be any,
it can be an open microphone.
I'm next and I start getting this,
the shortness of breath.
I have to turn around and look down the
stairs at the comedy store just by me
knowing that I could get out if shit
goes down.
I'm okay.
Hm.
So I don't think a fucking tubs got
windows are floating tank.
They seal that thing over here,
you know,
they don't seal.
It's just,
that's what I'm a little scared of it.
I'm not claustrophobic either.
I was in the cell.
None of that shit bothers me.
I just got to see a window.
Yeah.
Well listen,
it's,
it's real easy,
like when you're in it,
it's right there.
You just lift your hand up and it's
right there.
The door's right there.
I know we had to stand up.
You open the door.
It's on your hat.
You know,
look what happened yesterday and in
Barcelona.
What a fucking shame.
You can't conduct terrorist attacks to
isolation.
Well,
let me ask you a question,
Joe Rogan.
I even know that I asked you a question.
My brother,
you were an intelligent individual.
You're an intelligent individual,
pumps or Jamie,
you're not a fucking Phi Beta Kappa,
but you know,
Jamie might be the smartest guy in the
random.
I'm just teasing you,
Jamie.
How many people were looking down when
they got hit by that car yesterday?
Let's be honest.
60 five people got hit,
but you know,
that's,
you know,
people are start paying attention as
Americans.
You cannot live in that fucking thing no
more.
We cannot.
It's not smart.
It's not smart to be walking around
staring up fucking.
But sometimes you have to look at it.
Oh,
there's,
there's times where like someone of
course sends you an address,
you're meeting people there.
Then there's times you catch yourself.
You're like,
what am I going?
What am I doing?
All three of us have children.
Do we want our children to grow up on a
fucking computer?
Do we want them to have both?
They're going to grow up on computers.
You're not going to.
I,
I want them to grow up in computers,
but I don't want that whole lifestyle to
be on the computer.
I want them to go outside.
I want them to get dirty.
I want them to have life experiences.
Even if you know,
the only way you learn about life is
sometimes by having a negative,
something negative happening.
So true.
Then these children that are on my
computer to the 18,
then they send them away and they
fucking fractured.
Yeah,
fractured with two different time now
for children guys and we're parents.
It's a different time.
It's way different.
It's different in the way that I don't
think anybody's ever seen before,
so they don't know what the fuck.
What the fuck to do Tom Scott under p
lookout?
Slimiest.
Beautiful,
beautiful,
sexy.
I try and keep it as normal as I can.
I try to keep it as normal as I can.
I never want to forget who the fuck I
am.
Joe Rogan and I don't want to forget it
for my children.
My daughter,
you know,
I don't want them to be.
I was driving home and I saw a little
girl selling lemonade with her mom on
the corner was 2000 degrees and in
studio city I pull up to my house.
I go inside and get my daughter and I
get the,
my,
my wife.
Let's go buy some fucking eliminated
from this kid.
All right.
My daughter's going to kindergarten next
year at a school that's rated one of the
highest schools,
but it's a public school approach.
Kids go there,
a bunch of kids go.
There is no reason to put your kid in
these Notre Dame's and all these
$25,000.
They want $34,000
a year for kindergarten.
Why come on Joe Rogan?
What?
Well,
how is your child going to benefit?
Come on.
We're all intelligent here.
That's $24,000,
monarch,
Notre Dame,
all the other schools in the valley.
They want 30 gs,
two g registration form to sign your kid
in.
Really joke.
People want to keep their kids say no,
that's not safe,
and so you could tell your friends that
your kids are fucking that school.
That's a little bit of size.
Hold on.
My kids attend and you're like,
oh my God,
you're kidding.
Attempt to be a fucking dummy because
he's in school with other rich people's
fucking kids and they're all fucking
dummies to you know that getting raised
by Nannies.
I don't want that.
I don't.
I go to the park.
How many fucking white kids do you see
where Mexican women,
they got a fucking shame.
The Mexican women are adopting the white
kids at fucked up.
That's why they didn't want to build a
wall because you got to raise their own
fucking kids.
That's why these white people didn't
want Mexicans to go.
California was going to raise their
fucking kids swimming coach.
I go to a swimming class Thursdays with
my daughter jumping in front.
There's no more white parents take of
their nannies.
I run the fucking wire MCA with their
kids.
When your kid grows up and he's.
What's his name?
My goal,
Napa.
Low Mile.
You know when he was one of those,
don't come crying to me.
Don't come to me and let me tell you
something.
The pacifier,
I was raised to be a little cock sucker,
but I snapped out of it.
Somewhat know when my father died,
when I was one of those little boys.
You see what that mom holding onto that
leg?
No,
go.
I was one of those little fucking faggot
kids.
Okay.
I stuck the pacifier until the age of
six.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I hope I had potential to be one thing.
One fucking thing.
You understand me?
But my mother would not allow that shit
that happened.
Don't Latin mothers don't play that
Shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh yeah.
Latin mothers do not allow that shit.
I couldn't wear scarves.
You know?
It was on the west coast.
We wanted to wear a scarf,
like a snoopy scarf,
like flags.
Like I was going to go fly a plane scarf
or what's it like one of those Randy
coture scarves?
Which although I wouldn't where I think
on him as quite fetching.
No,
no scarves.
No.
You ever see the Randy coture scarf?
Yeah.
Randy called Torah will.
Where would I would call a tactical
scarf.
Oh,
like that.
See,
that's the kind of scarf that like a
navy seal would where randy wears a
bunch of those things.
But Randy is such a bad motherfucker.
It's almost like he's begging you to try
to choke him.
What that thing can come.
Come and try to grab that thing.
I just leave.
That should be the name of that album
right there.
That should be his album.
Cover scarf.
Scarf.
It's crazy.
He's such a nice guy.
A rennies or anything.
You know what?
And His kid,
his kid,
uh,
came to my show in Vegas and also has
like a,
a gym that coolest,
coolest kid man.
Like him and his wife,
I think both teach there too.
Oh Wow.
Nice.
Nice man.
His son,
his son is.
Yeah,
I think he was fighting in the world
series of fighting,
which is now,
now is a new name,
but yeah,
he fought for a bunch of different
people.
Right.
To fight for strike force.
Now think he might've fought for Bella
tour.
Ryan coture,
talented fighter it.
While we're at it.
Don't forget to remind you as fucking
Gino giving you the CBD Roll-on on yet.
Yes.
What do you think?
It's amazing.
How does that even work?
Is that Buddha dogs?
I came home,
I scored it like a cream.
You Rub it on like spotify for my wife
moves.
You really get out of the shower,
done it gets in weird spots.
Dog must have some sort of anti
inflammatory properties or something
like that.
Do you like that?
Tie?
Lindemann.
Everybody.
Anybody ever rubbed that stuff on?
You know,
like ties,
like Thai boxers and shit.
They're like,
you got to realize they're always
dealing with like bones slamming into
their legs and they're all sore and shit
and they rubbed this tie.
Linament.
It's weird.
It's like Kiehl's
valley stuff.
I don't think it heals up man,
but it makes sure it feels good.
It's a similar one.
Tiger Balm.
Like that girl Shit.
I have another thing.
It's called something juice and when I
was a kid I used to have the I am poem
bag and I rubbed it on my hands and do
the I am poem technique and Shit.
With that it's called something that has
a weird smell to it.
Like does this stuff do like when?
When,
when that stuff like heats your skin up
and you're like,
Oh God,
like a icy hot.
Like that kind of shit.
What does that really doing?
I have no idea.
I think it's just tricking you into
thinking.
So yeah,
I don't think it really is someone who's
a friend of mine who's a doctor
described it as a topical analgesic,
meaning that it,
it does something to the surface of your
skin,
but maybe is it psychological that makes
you feel like it's healing up?
Like when you have a muscle soreness or
something like that,
like if you have like a wound,
a little injury,
there's a psychology psychological
aspect to that heat and stuff.
I feel like you think you're getting
work done.
You know,
there's probably a psychological aspect
to healing in general.
I don't think it's 100 percent,
but I think you could sway it in a
better direction.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean like that's got to be what the
placebo effect is,
right?
They tell you they're going to give you
a pill and it's gonna make you feel bad
and you're like,
oh,
this is it.
This is the thing they gave me.
The gave me the pill,
and you actually do feel better and even
show signs of recovery,
like immediately corresponding to you
taking that pill.
Like your brain is convinced yourself.
What about that dude you've had on the
podcast who's brain is like a fucking
healing serum who can walk Wim Hof?
Yeah.
Wim Hoff.
Oh yeah,
dude,
he's.
I mean,
he treats people.
He teaches people how to do it.
He's as legit as they get.
He holds the world record for swimming
under ice ice.
Yes,
and by the way,
he fucked up and couldn't figure out
which way to get out because his retinas
had frozen over because the water was so
cold.
How does he do this?
He's an an em all.
He's a fucking savage.
That guy in the most beautiful sense of
the word,
he just has incredible breath control.
That's a big part of his whole entire
philosophy.
So the guys following this rope once
he's committed to it,
by the way,
like he's just got these little spots
along the way where he can get some air,
but he lost track.
He couldn't see good anymore because it
was so god damn cold.
He couldn't figure out where the exit
is,
so he went more than the full distance.
That was his goal in the first place,
which was insane.
All of it's insane.
Oh,
fucking name,
man.
I mean that guy is something special.
He teaches people,
which is the crazier part even to me
that he's.
He's gotten people train them to swim in
freezing water,
walk through ice,
and also fight off a cold.
Yes,
yes.
Fuck me,
I use his breathing technique before
going on stage and when I do I have
better shows.
This is what I think.
I think you looked Kinda hyperoxygenate
and stimulate your mind how
sophisticated breathing tick.
Well it's a lot of what he does that I
find beneficial is like,
and I've heard this concept in yoga
before too,
is breathing in like take a giant breath
and letting out,
excuse me,
letting on about 20 percent and then
breathing in again as hard as you can,
let it out about 20 percent breathing in
as hard as you can and then continue
that for like long periods of time.
Dude,
I do that in the Cryo tank where I stand
in the cold air.
Yeah,
three minutes goes by like that.
There's a giant difference between when
I do that and when I don't do that.
So you focus on your breathing,
it's a little bit of that.
There's definitely,
there's something about people that are
encountering any sort of stimulation
where it's real hard to manage the
stimulation without letting everything
get fucking crazy and haywire and being
able to manage it has a gigantic effect
on what the actual results or the actual
experience of being this cold.
It's because it gets the same goddamn
thing,
but if you can control your breath and
control your consciousness and you're
doing something that seems to be heating
up your body to and a little bit of a
way,
almost like an internal exercise because
it's difficult to do because you're
taking these big giant breasts of cold
air and then you're letting out a little
and then you take it a big giant breath.
It's almost like you're flexing your
lungs and when you do that man,
I mean it might make it 20,
30 percent easier to deal with three
minutes supposedly.
I'm not kidding.
One of the Olympics,
I don't know what year it is.
If you'd like to check whether the
Russians beat the fuck out of the
Americans.
Supposedly Americans came out walking
you the flag and the Russian Joel Cave.
I'm going,
Whoa,
whoa.
And they couldn't figure out what the
fuck is wrong with these motherfuckers.
That's what they were doing.
They warm up their lungs,
looked back to think about what they're
about to do,
the technique they're about to use,
and to let the blood go to the back of
something fucking weird.
I read about that was pretty
interesting.
Whether it's true or not,
I don't know,
but supposedly that cardio was so ahead
of the United States because they were
doing a pre breathing exercises.
Thinking had something to do.
Now is that the guy that also has the
record for the deepest drop?
I think it's a different guy,
a different guy,
a different guy.
He's the one that I wrote that I read
about.
He used the one that wrote about about
how you have to prepare for all that
stuff and that it was learned when the
Russians came up at the.
It's interesting to focus on your
breath,
like I don't do it much.
I do.
I actually been doing polities and it's
way fucking harder than I thought it was
gonna be,
but be like,
you're thinking about your breath for
like an hour.
Basically.
You're always.
You're always working on your breath.
There's not.
It's not a secret
that like the greatest Jujitsu guy of
all time had this crazy breath control.
Really Hixon Gracie.
He had.
There's a bunch of videos of him.
He received a documentary choke.
You ever heard of it?
No.
It's an amazing documentary about this
Guy Hixon Gracie,
who's almost universally regarded as the
greatest Jujitsu player of all time and
fought a bunch of fights in mma and
strangled everybody fought,
but he.
There's this video where he's doing this
yoga warm up sort of thing that he would
do every day and he does this thing with
his stomach that you watch them do this
and it starts warming his stomach up.
He's doing this like fire breathing
shit,
but then he starts sucking his stomach
into like the upper corners of his rib
cage,
like rhythmically in this like almost
impossible thing.
Like can you watching them doing it?
Like he's warming everything up and then
once he gets it warmed up,
you starts wiggling the internals.
But look at this man.
Who the fuck has that kind of control of
your abdominal muscles to do this?
Every time he trained,
he did it all the time.
Did it constantly.
He did this,
he did yoga constantly.
Gymnastics.
He did a type of yoga called a gymnastic
gun,
not trial,
which is a Brazilian.
I'm a sort of a,
um,
a combination of yoga and a lot of
movements like rolling and animal,
like movements,
natural movements,
amazing stuff.
See if he could find the guy who created
that gymnastica natural.
So you give the guy credit because
there's a really amazing style carriers.
Yes.
So her into gymnastics as a couple of
Brazilian guy teaching decimals is
actually so much more bad ass than it's
given credit for Jiu Jitsu.
No,
no,
I'm talking about like gymnast's for
sure.
Or even like yoga masters.
Oh yeah.
Physical ability is so beyond.
I think most people's perception of it
when they first,
you know,
think about it.
Like,
yeah,
fucking Psychos,
man.
Professor Alvarado Romano is the guy who
created gymnastic unnatural and uh,
that was Hickson's thing and there's
videos of him doing it,
doing it on the beach.
There's a video of Hicks and doing it,
and um,
you watch the movements and you go,
oh,
this is almost like he's having,
like,
it's almost like shadow fighting with
Jujitsu because you're being able to put
your body in these weird positions over
and over and over again to balance
yourself,
saw a bunch of controlling your body in
any weird way that you could possibly
encounter a position where you'd have to
be strong wild shit because he was way
ahead of the curve man.
There was everybody back then was to,
in Mexican supplements and Dead Lifts
and bench pressing and fucking running
over each other and training camp,
beating the shit out of each other.
And Hickson was just strangling people.
You know,
it's really a fascinating thing when you
stop and think about it,
that this one guy was the best and so
far ahead of the curve.
And so few people,
even people that really got into
Jujitsu,
saw,
well,
first of all,
he had amazing talent as dad was Leo,
grace it.
Those are two giant factors,
but also the way he trained and the way
he controlled his breath and his own
son,
Kron Gracie was world champion or the
best grapplers in the world can do all
that stuff too,
has massive breath control and he'll
tell you,
it's all about your breath.
Like being able to control your breath
is a massive part of your anxiety levels
to massive part of how you can deal with
stress,
how you can calm yourself down.
You have control and power over your
lungs.
What does this too?
Oh,
this is another.
He's out there in the jungle.
This guys actually doing it in the
jungle.
Jacques already does a lot of that
stuff.
We all breathe naturally will make.
If you look at your children,
they are breathing the way that we're
supposed to breathe somewhere with 10 or
12 or become a teenager.
Yeah,
we go off like my breathing was
complete.
I went to seminars.
I went to digital.
Really,
when I went to Jujitsu,
I created so much fear in my mind from
being on my back that I would
immediately run outside and take my gear
off and pee my pants and people would
quit.
Like I just pay a little bit of my short
term.
Most people would have quit.
Yeah.
I don't like that feeling.
So I kept going back and I wouldn't
improve.
I would improve because of my car.
Yeah.
I had been smoking joints for 30 years.
Yeah,
I'm a fat fuck.
it was that I had a bill,
but like I had to get Bob's route,
his mouthpiece to build my diaphragm
just to suck.
I had no therapy.
All of this because of Jujitsu is legit.
The boss routing thing is legit.
When I hit the bag,
I use the bus route and thing.
Yeah.
I think what they're saying is the best
way to use it.
Just use it and it's an exercises
exercise.
Use It,
use it like an exercise.
So let's do a few things with it and
just blow some air out with it.
Like really good.
It's really helped me,
but that's how much I learned about like
I now I don't have as much anxiety.
I breathe it out.
It really fucking.
So I've done a lot of reading about it,
but that guy's article,
but the guy that dipped the longest,
his was the most interesting.
I didn't know about the fucking license
shit,
but it's true,
man.
Once you.
Now I'm rolling and now I pulled guard
with time just to be on my back.
I want to be fearful.
Yeah.
So I just couldn't.
I just look back whenever I have a
problem.
I do a thing called who got hula bowl
that the Indians did Hulu,
where you look,
hookah,
Lou,
something like that.
Oh,
who could allow hookah lounge where you
look up and you center again.
Yeah.
That's helped me become a better comment
sometimes up there talking shit and just
center yourself and all these little
things I learned because I joined
Jujitsu like my breathing or I focus on
it when I rolled.
Now I don't care about hands no more.
I don't care if you're choked me.
I really don't give a fuck.
I'm horrible anyway.
I'm just,
I'm just learning to breathe all over
it,
you know,
I'm just learning to breathe,
I was grabbing you and trying to go for
a cross collar and then fucking like
doing something completely different for
assistant sweep and somebody like Joe.
You got to exhale brother.
Do you do,
do,
do a yoga for Jujitsu?
Don't they have a class like shit down
at um,
schools?
Yeah,
yeah,
we do.
I go early.
What's the name of the actual thing is
called TAC fit.
But I go to yoga with my wife once a
week.
We'd just go there.
She goes four times.
I just go with the Tuesday one just to
loosen up from 10 to 11.
I'm not that good at it.
My rich fit is our friends tack for this
or Scott Sewn and fuzzy when they
realized who he did the podcast with me
fucking happen.
A tremendous workshop.
This wreck ain't fucking nine to five
every day.
Shit.
Saturday and Sunday.
Are they teaching you?
Kettlebells meets club bells with glossy
and how it affects Jujitsu and mma and
stuff like that.
So last week I got to meet Scott Simon
and boy,
he's fucking great joe.
He's got a lot of great stuff about
bell's yes,
scraping some of his videos.
Listen,
I'm up to the 20 pounds from Barbara.
Yeah.
I started when I first got the club
bells from heartbreak.
My wrist was hurting with five pounds.
I couldn't even do the simple five
pounds one.
Now I'm taking twenties,
holding them,
going all the way back,
bringing them back and it's all focused
on my back and breathing.
That's it.
I just threw shit to breathe.
Now I don't give a fuck if I get beat up
because that's what was really bothering
me was the breathing and maybe getting
better at it.
Yeah.
But now I'm getting better at it.
Plus the sleep apnea had put a lot of
fear.
So being on my back and being out of
breath,
have sleep apnea would kick in again.
You got fucking,
you know.
So
do you ever do those shield casts?
What's that?
Remember the iron sheik.
Remember the iron sheik used to hold up
those gigantic,
a Iranian clubs that they would use for
wrestling training.
It's like it was a really strong move
for wrestling training,
see if he could find what would the iron
sheik cause he was like the iron sheik
people don't know.
He was a pro wrestler in the wwe.
He was wwf back then and you know,
he was before he was that he was a super
successful Iranian amateur wrestler.
He was a legit wrestler,
like legit wrestling skills and
ridiculously strong and he's holding
these things and I don't know how much
these things way,
but they,
it doesn't look like he's faking this
because of the slow motion of how he's
moving in.
They look like heavy objects.
I don't know how much they weigh,
but this is a really hard workout to do.
You know,
I,
I can barely do that shit with like 15
pounds and I'm not bullshitting with one
hand.
It's hard.
It's a weird control thing.
And you realize like how you're strong
in certain areas as a definitely
heaviest,
heaviest fuck yeah.
You're strong in certain areas.
Like that guy is super jacked.
Who is that?
Got Beautiful underwear.
Um,
but it's,
it's a very difficult thing because you
could be really strong when it comes to
like a straight shoulder press,
you know,
like you could like hoist up like 70
pounds,
but there's no fucking way in the world
you're going to be moving around 70
pounds of fat.
You're just,
you just can't do it.
Your arm's going to fall off.
Like if you have,
especially if you have it in the form of
a club,
like you can't even get close.
Like I can do a lot of shit with heavy
kettle bells.
But when it comes to like one of those
clubs,
I'd take two hands to move around a 30
pound one,
which is like if someone says like 30
pounds,
like do you bench press $30 Bro.
That's all we got here.
Thirty pounds bro.
I can't even get up pump doing something
with one of these clubs.
That's 30 pounds is fucking insane.
Saying you have to be so God damn
strong.
And that sounds weird because it seems
like,
well 30 pounds is 30 pounds,
but when you start swinging that shit
over your head and it's long.
And so like the leverage is going
against you look at him like a fucking
bulldozer too.
He was a bulldozer guy that's on twitter
calling everybody and everybody's all my
dates,
Nazis.
I retweeted them the other day about
I love him.
I was onstage with him in Toronto is one
of my favorite moments as a human calm
people that you're bronies called
everybody a piece of shit.
I fucking hated everybody.
He was a good man though.
And he was a stud wrestler.
But there's the dark secret of not just
professional wrestling but of I'm just
real high,
real high level grappling.
So the damage that gets done to a lot of
those guys bodies is almost unfixable.
And he's all fucked up now he's got,
you know,
like flares,
like not in a coma,
but in the last four or five days.
I heard about that.
And how old is Rick Flair?
You know?
Um,
they pay a price,
they pay a price to,
to entertain in that way,
know it's very,
very physically violent.
It just,
because it's not quote unquote a real
fight,
whereas like there's an unplanned
outcome and they're just throwing
haymakers at each other,
like a real mma fight.
Just because it's not.
That doesn't mean that they're not
taking in a lot of damage.
Hit with those fucking forearms.
Shivers and dropped a fucking chair on
them.
Like all that shit is fucking them up.
A lot of them had brain damage to a lot
of it.
I'm sure there's no sugar,
there's no studies on it,
but I'm sure I'm sure some of them
avoided it.
You know,
some of them fought smart.
And what is he saying?
What is that boy saying?
His Song?
I thought it was Halloween.
Well,
this is a drop bees silo.
What does
he say?
Ghetto boys.
What was that like?
Oh my God,
I haven't heard that in so long.
What song is that?
Oh,
it's a halloween song,
right?
We with chicken up the place.
What's that face?
Somebody playing tricks on me.
Yeah,
that's.
It wasn't no more than every seven feet,
whatever.
We triple team them,
dropping them motherfucking bed.
The more I do,
the more I swung,
the more blood flow.
Debbie disappeared and then my boys
disappeared too.
Wow.
That's a classic man.
Oh my God.
Bushwick bill.
Ladies and gentlemen,
remember the cover?
The cover of a ghetto boy CD is
Bushwick.
Bill with his eye shot out in the
fucking.
Not,
not even this one.
It's another one in the Gurney.
The hospital and it's like we can't be
stopped.
Is the name of the album he got shot.
Delirious man.
I think he shot himself in the.
I don't even know what the fuck
happened.
Someone shot him in the eye and he's
like,
we can't be stopped.
And he's in the Gurney,
like look at this.
Oh yeah,
right.
Damn.
Yeah.
So he's on the phone.
He's got one of them breaks.
He's got one of them brick cell phones
from the olden days,
from back in the Gordon Gekko days.
Guys on playing games and so he got shot
in the eye and while that's happening
he's on the phone doing deals.
Do deals still doing deals and it was
the comments they had because they were
pushing this.
Whoa,
whoa.
Why don't we pick up pictures?
We could put this up.
Yo.
We got to take a picture of this.
Let me take this off right quick.
Let me take this bandage off right
quick.
Oh my God,
man.
Yeah.
The WHO's the midget?
That's,
that's horrible nomenclature,
sir.
I,
I don't think John Wesley,
John Wesley,
and saw him fucking changing the flat
one to Houston and he pulled over to
help Bushwick bill was.
How cool was that?
I helped Bushwick bill.
I met.
Well,
he did a show once he came to a show.
Didn't you?
Skipped one of my favorite quotes all
the time.
He got a little hobby of,
whoa.
It's totally.
He's totally right.
And he really did.
Shoot is io really did.
Oh yeah.
That wasn't a publicity stunt.
Look at that.
Damn.
That's crazy.
Imagine that face walking up to you.
They were like at a store and just be
like,
I'm a celebrity.
God fucking ice shot out.
They were fucking huge at one time.
Geto boys for sure,
to live crew that we can't be stopped.
We can't be stopped as a big fucking
album.
They were huge.
No,
I used to listen to them when I was on
the treadmill master a fucking
stairmaster things.
Whatever.
The.
His rap a lot.
Right.
And isn't that the Houston a label?
Wasn't that rap a lot?
They put us on the map.
Rap a lot.
That's exactly what it was.
That's right.
Because the white dude with the teeth.
Oh,
Paul Wall.
He still makes teeth.
Teeth.
Does he make grills?
He makes great show.
You should get Paul Wall grills.
We should all get grilled.
That's a good idea.
For Real.
That's a great Christmas and some death
squad was let.
Let's fucking do it.
Will you do it please?
Please do it.
How many teeth?
Let's just get a row,
man.
Let's just do around when we go to Paul.
What's up Joe Rogan?
One thousand days.
You've got your lips.
No,
it's fine man.
What if it gets hooked up on your wife's
push?
That's cool too.
If it's diamonds should be fooled with
it.
For the denture grills,
how much denture grills?
Let's see that.
What's the cost on that?
Those are the ones you slide right off.
Fucking diamond grill cheese.
What about people that want to be
diamond page?
Twenty 400.
That's not bad.
Twenty $400 for jewelry and your teeth.
Just to let everybody know you're not
playing by any.
You're definitely right.
If you meet a dude and he's a number of
gold teeth,
like the number of gold teeth,
he as direct proportion as to whether or
not he's a pirate.
Dude,
shoot your next special.
Wearing these motherfuckers.
Let people know what time it is,
man.
I'm serious.
J R dot e dot and then put the name of
the special in the bottom.
I need a hype man.
I've been thinking to call you on this.
Would love to figure out like what's my
best strategy.
I'm trying to hype out.
Is that a word?
You know what I would do as soon as you
hit like a big punchline,
I will go and that was fucking funny to
get them wrapped up.
You fucking John.
What he makes her.
You just showing up and going.
Yeah.
Yeah,
a lot.
Like 50 grand fucking I'm sure man.
Well,
wasn't John Stays pay was like Paris
Hilton was like,
one of the biggest things she had was
like those nightclub appearances.
She'd go and they would just pay her the
money.
Yeah,
just to just show up and I ended up for
some guy gave her a club.
It was called club Paris.
Every one was supposed to come show up
and like she was supposed to be there
every weekend.
She's not going to Orlando every weekend
obviously.
So is that the idea that he had?
How cooked up are you when you get in
business with Paris Hilton?
I got an idea.
I'm going to give her a club.
Is that cool?
They see it.
You see the connection.
If you're.
If you're hearing this guy who made that
deal.
I'm sorry,
I'm just joking around.
I don't really think that one day we'll
fucking that like when we first go into
the comedy store sunset,
when you hit Laurel Canyon,
it was bumper to bumper traffic.
Right?
Okay.
It was bumper
to bumper traffic.
I remember getting a ticket one time
because I had my spot was up.
I just want it in the Middle Lane.
There was a cop right there.
Fucking wait with me by the standard,
you know,
that was when Hilton and what's the
other chick that was getting in trouble?
Lindsay Lohan.
She's got locked out every fucking nice
true causing problems.
And then Lindsay Lohan and went to the
griddle before court.
One day she went to that place that we
went to the breakfast place,
a good place and that was it.
After that,
the griddle was packed for fucking
months after that because people found
out lindsay was only going there for
breakfast every morning and they had
those crazy pancakes.
Pancakes.
I mean,
but I'm saying that it's like 18
pancakes.
I'm wondering like there's your pancake
nuts kill you,
kill you.
Take care of for you.
Like 15 years ago there was French
Press.
They were fucking years ago.
Yeah,
friends.
Yeah.
Fifteen years ago.
They had coffee from Hawaii there.
They were doing a good job there.
I just don't like waiting on line.
Fags,
Bro.
I'm anti waiting on line.
I'm not waiting in line for a
restaurant.
I mean when something kind of reasonable
fine.
Obviously it's like your table.
You don't have a table used to hang out,
but when they're like,
this place is awesome.
Just hour and a half now.
Ever done.
Franklin's barbecue in Austin stayed in
line.
I'm not paying somebody $8 an hour.
Get My fucking hell and come out and get
more fucking waitresses.
The one cent hamburger place,
they do it.
They got people out there I don't like.
I think it's just a place to be cool.
Some people sit there for eight bucks an
hour for you already likes that Shit.
Doesn't sit in there and listen.
Nothing.
I don't want to wait for nothing.
When I go to breakfast and Hollywood,
if I got to go to the doctor,
I stopped by the griddle first before I
get there.
It's still a little wine,
but if they give me any drama,
there's a Bagel place across the street
that's tremendous to get a nice clean
Turkey,
bobby that make fresh Turkey and pull on
your Bagel,
bobby and he fucking around Jack.
The best wizard job at all.
Hollywood is pinks.
Yeah.
That's the worst day.
They are damned wizard.
Horrific.
I remember horrific coming like moving
here to the first thing you do and
you're like,
wow,
I hit that spot.
That line again.
You get one of those hot dogs.
He went all dark during the hot dogs.
No,
actually you actually bought into it and
you're like,
this is amazing.
And then.
Well then you take.
Then you take another bite and you're
like,
no,
I,
I just,
I just hype myself wanting to take a
minute.
Yeah,
but listen,
fuck us.
That place is crowded every God damn
near every day.
No.
It's about cooking outdoors to having
that open window.
When she walked by and you could see
them cooking the hot dogs.
I went in there and the buttons were
pink.
The bunge were yellow.
The Chili was God awful.
You know what the problem is?
God awful.
The real problem for me is always going
to be that I've had real New York
hot dog snap when you bite them bread,
you know there's those type of hot dogs
that they were making.
The buns were perfect.
Lungs go so far with Burgers,
amazing things,
but there's something about when you
snap into one of those and you taste
that real fresh,
real delicious hot dog tastes like a
regular bullshit hot dogs.
They just don't fly anymore.
Like when you go to dodger stadium,
those are the worst hot dog ever know
Adam curls and some sort of a beef with
fans about that.
If a dog's,
it's God awful.
It's like you read.
Don't feel from American Airlines.
Think you're poisoning yourself.
Every time I get the oatmeal from
America and I'm like,
am I fucking poison?
Those dodger dogs are so fucking bad.
They're horrible.
I don't give a fuck what anybody says
when I was in the
from junior year.
Uh,
what's that word?
Excoriates.
He excoriates the dodger dog.
Implores ramps to serve better beef.
What does that word have you ever used?
Lord,
wow,
whoever you are,
word wizard of Google.
My junior year in high school,
Mr Hildebrand took us to the fucking sad
brett place to take this through a
little walk,
you know,
because his job was to do is to every
month to show is different career
opportunities and we went to this,
this hotdog thing that like we had to
take a bus down there.
Have you ever seen that?
No.
Okay.
So this for Puerto Rican and about boobs
and they got yellow suits on and they
got those boots on.
Okay.
And there's a fucking I could,
you know when you're working on a
construction site and you throw the
sheet rock in the tube and the tube goes
down to the first floor into the
dumpster.
Okay.
So there's a tube like that.
And then this for Puerto Ricans were
brewing and then six Puerto Rican with
bags of 80 pounds.
Ninety pounds salt.
This is back in 1980.
Okay.
Ninety pounds and there's pallets of 90
pounds at every once in a while,
but light turns red and this thing just
body parts start falling heads,
shoulders,
eyeballs.
You just see it and then these guys,
the other Puerto Rican break the bags of
salt and put them on this shit that's
folly,
like it's not stopped and these guys
sweep that into a fucking hole and
that's how the hot dog gets.
But it's everything.
It's the leg the whole time,
you know?
What do you think?
What happens to her leg when somebody
gets into a car?
So the four or five when you think
happens to the leg,
you think they'd take it home?
Fuck No.
They call Hormel Hormel.
We got a black leg for you.
It's about three pounds.
I will call you back in five minutes.
Then they call white castle lizard,
but we have a deal for you.
Then they hang up with him and they call
state comes and they send that Lego
thing do with that big fucking leg that
weighs 300 pounds.
You think they just put that leg away?
Fuck no,
that's you.
Could you imagine if they found out that
people were,
were grinding up people,
they found them
morgue dogs.
If that was true,
the male will kill him and he had a
friend that had a supermarket but owed
them money,
so at night he'd go kill them in the
supermarket and put them in the meat
grinder and the next day people come in
and put that meet.
What the fuck were you eating when it
was over in net?
Fuck he ground Plato's leftover in
there?
Yeah,
for a couple of a couple of his murders.
He had a guy that don't want the money
for Shylock and he was like a.
It wasn't any training.
People training people training them
upside down and training people.
The other guy from the Gambia and I was
on the chain
supermarkets,
you know that.
That was the guy from the gambling.
The other guy from the Gambinos owned
great web,
great white auto memo.
When you're in queens and shit,
they have those people that balance your
tires and shit.
All them was that bought into legit
businesses.
That was a good way to declare income.
Yeah.
I think I had the guy that the the heavy
guy conti is something.
That guy was a known heroine dealer.
He was on the board of Director of news
bombs of a supermarket you want me to
say with this motherfucker that they had
about 30 rest their head about 30
supermarkets in the Jersey area and one
day he just called local two.
Oh,
two carpenters and said,
do me a favor,
go to every supermarket and add an
aisle.
So every supermarket had an aisle that
whatever they took went directly to the
mom.
But.
So they had 13 supermarkets were like on
number five,
wasn't really on number five.
Nobody knew about number five.
So whatever was bought in that aisle,
that cash went upstairs for 13
supermarkets on a daily basis.
They would just go into a supermarket
and it had two lanes go.
We don't even worry about those two
lights.
Wow.
How fucking bizarre is that?
Yeah.
Just,
it's crazy that the FBI,
all the people,
various law enforcement organizations
figuring out a way to crack that,
break it down.
They cracked it after they made 10
million.
Then they cracked it.
You know,
lives in studio city,
Bro,
who?
I just met him at the coffee shop about
three months ago.
And I talk to them all the time and I'm
about to sic 'em loose on people sick.
I'm loose on people who.
The last godfather in this country was a
guy by the name of Joe,
something big fat guy.
He came out and he may never be shut.
He was fucking genius.
Joe came out of jail,
man,
everybody's shut.
The social clubs,
everybody had to have a job.
Everybody had to have a job,
no drugs.
Everybody stuck to it.
They were doing phenomenal.
He was doing phenomenal Joe Massino,
but somebody was shaking down a
restaurant and he went in there and they
were giving him $20,000
a week for security.
So they couldn't figure out how to get
Messina because he wasn't doing anything
outside.
And they got this forensic accountant to
go in there and they shut down the mine.
This guy,
well this guy retired lives in fucking
studio city.
We were talking to one day goes for a
thousand bucks.
So it gives you a hard time.
You have the right to go in there and
look at their books.
He goes,
don't bring.
No,
he's fucking white.
It is from Hollywood,
bring me because I'll find everything in
there.
Plus I'm making a deal.
If they don't pay it,
I call my friends at the fucking irs and
I will have him here within a day
looking through your ass hole.
So we're ready to sick mother fuckers.
I got one guy I'm ready to say,
come on.
He keeps telling me,
Oh,
we haven't made any money.
Keep it up.
Keep it up because I'm going to stick
this little fucking.
And this guy is one of those.
He's not even Jewish.
He's just crazy and white,
but for a thousand bucks he'll go in
there and he was the same guy that
brought down thousands of people for the
FBI.
When they can't figure you out forensic
accounting,
you're done the math better add up Jack
Jesus.
Correct.
So anybody who gives you guys a hard
time,
we don't know.
We haven't sold a lot of them.
Thousand Bucks and he'll go in there and
he's fucking.
When you look at him,
he's one of those white dudes that did
30 years in the marines that he's pretty
serious.
He goes,
I'll rip them fucking open for you.
Oh,
I'll find every dime and then I'll make
them an offer they can't refuse that.
They got three days to give you a check
for the UN,
whatever.
Or we contact our buddies and the irs
now having met in 24 hours to look in
your asshole until they find something
or is that true?
Can you really do that?
Whatever the fuck you call the irs and
go,
hey man,
watch your ass or wait till you see the
end of the year.
We went to all these people who've been
talking shit about trump.
You think Kathy Griffin's they're not
going to get harassed and anybody else
you watch.
I don't trust trump when it comes to
something like that.
I'm not saying he's a bad dude or
anything like that,
but I'm saying is trump's one of those
dudes.
You really don't want to mess with it.
I believe that.
I believe that if people want to put
pressure on you,
they could get you to the irs.
I think agencies had been doing it for
years.
I shouldn't even trump.
What did you guys think of this
Charlottesville stuff and his reaction
to it?
I think he's just a big failure man.
I mean he.
What was he,
what did you feel like when he fumbled
on what I thought was two levels,
like,
so there's the,
there's the leadership like presidential
level,
right where you go,
like this is the office that we look to
and then there's the person.
So I think he,
it's weird how he makes,
you know,
everything is about him.
And he even started one of those press
conferences and it went like
how the economy's doing.
So like,
I think it's hard to view that dude
morally as somebody that you're,
I don't know that you would enjoy being
around as a person.
And then I get,
I actually,
I get what he was trying to do.
I do to,
with his,
uh,
criticizing and tif and stuff like I,
I,
you know,
I get it,
but like it's the lack of savviness is
even maybe more like in,
in not knowing like this is a time where
you do this and not that,
that's also something you're like,
wow.
Like he just just feels like it's
totally unfit for the job in my opinion,
while I also feel like when you're,
when you're the president,
the workload must be impossible to
imagine before you get in there and then
once you get in there you're dealing
with all these pressures,
all these super important decisions and
all these different areas and then some
new shit comes up.
I've,
I really think,
and I'm not even seeing this as a
critical of like I don't like him.
I really think he is the only a few
other people can experience this is
truly like,
Holy Shit with what this job entails.
I think so too.
I think it's really like one of those
things where he's like,
wow.
And you can see that he's constantly.
Like he always refers to the campaign
still always in any conversation we'll
talk about like I beat those guys
because I think that's the part that he
enjoyed.
He enjoyed the competition days of the
campaign and I think like,
and then you know,
he's always bringing up like the new.
But the dad was setting records for for
months and months and months,
but like he'll still tweets will be
about that or interviews will be about
that.
He can't not make a conversation,
a statement with talking to.
It probably is a connection though
between the Dow,
the up and him being an office and
people thinking that he's friendly to
business to business markets.
Love it.
There's definitely no doubt about that.
But there's also no doubt that
unemployment was at record lows and
setting records beforehand and the Dow
has been breaking.
Has been on an upswing for years now.
Isn't that how it always is?
Like presidents always come in and take
advantage of the upward.
There's,
of course he's not the first highly
predictive bucket that the economy does
come in.
These ebbs and flows.
It does come in,
abs and flows in the market.
Inevitably,
at least in in the history of it always
comes back,
always comes back.
You know,
if you.
Even if you stayed through like black
Monday,
if you.
The market's still eventually comes
back.
I'm too stupid to understand that I'm
too stupid to get the market.
You know you're not.
No,
no,
no.
I mean I am in the sense that I'm not
really interested in pursuing those
lines of thought.
I get that.
That's different.
My brain is just like,
yeah,
that seems like a pot of shit to me.
I gotta get Outta here.
If I tell you I to believe this,
I don't know if it happened.
Market Street from white supremacists.
Somebody showed up.
Oh,
I don't pay attention to disconnect with
myself.
I don't watch world my whole life.
I tell you what happened.
Let me tell you what happens is through
photo
shoots,
they finished goods is that spray that
makes everybody gay that they put on
frogs.
They're now using at j.
crew like you know,
like Abercrombie and Fitch does as you
walk in and they hit you with that.
That gay frog spray you.
What I'm talking about,
it makes you guys.
So a bunch of dudes got crazy tattooed
swastikas on themselves,
took their shirts off.
They're all walking around with
citronella candles that they got from
like a hardware store.
That was the stupidest part of it all
they had,
they had like torches out.
They're walking on the street with like,
come on,
you guys are walking around with lawn
torches,
pussies.
They didn't even make the Frankenstein
one where you get the fucking blame,
the fucking gas run and chase to go
fucking mosquito repellency shit.
Listen dog.
I tell you what this is.
You know what man?
I have so many things on my plate.
I had to stop watching.
Tell you something else.
I,
I had to sit in my wife down like a man
and tell about csm.
BC was not allowed of the house no more.
My wife is very political and I had to
cut her off like I can't have too much
drama.
It's overwhelming.
I can't have the tools to the table,
you know,
we would go out to dinner and somebody
would bring something up and I had to
kick her under the table and I feel bad.
Let's not talk about that shit.
Yeah.
There's no reason.
You know,
how you hear that expression more than,
you know,
as a kid where people were like never
bring up politics or religion,
religion.
Right.
And as a kid you're like,
I don't understand why that,
but this is,
I feel like the age where it becomes the
most clear and,
and at,
at the time where you're like,
oh,
I told we can actually probably have a
good time if no one talks about these
things.
And it always comes up guys.
You can't see for people talk for five
minutes about anything without somebody
bringing something up political.
And you know what?
At the end of the week,
dog,
you still gotta get up and go to work.
You still gotta get up her groceries.
She still gotta wipe your ass.
All of this knowledge and gops and slds.
I grew up in Hudson county,
New Jersey,
which comes into the Cook County,
Illinois.
Yeah.
So I learned about politics and a micro.
What's a smaller one?
Micro.
And it's a horrible thing.
I benefited from it.
I had no show jobs.
I had to rip down,
show jobs.
I had a no show job at harvest med
school when I was a kid going there once
a week and pick up a check and laugh at
the old Japanese.
I didn't.
I never moved the desk,
no Karma and got me the job,
got arrested.
So.
But it's a,
I saw the level.
It never interested me.
Like I was like,
these people fucking pukes they're
fucking puke.
Zoot suits on.
You know,
before you guys were talking about
taxpayer pay money,
I want to see the agenda for the 12
fucking idiots that sit there with suits
to the old and white and they sit there
and 12 hours to make a decision.
That's where our money goes.
Yeah.
You know,
you don't know about bureaucracy till my
mother died.
That's where I learned about bureaucracy
to 4:15.
That's why I don't like it because my
mother died.
I couldn't even collect social security
without coming up with 92 sheets of
paper.
That's a fucking social security number.
That's a fucking name.
And that's when she died.
And that's an exit ticket.
Give me my fucking money.
Oh No.
It's another letter.
And another meeting,
and you paid your taxes,
you paid for this.
This is your fucking harder than money.
That's when you learn that it's all
bullshit.
And this is all bullshit.
We are taxed in four years.
Your kids are gonna.
Come through and go daddy or your
daughter's gonna come to you and go,
I want to play basketball.
You take them down there.
If they charge you 85 to sign up dirty
too for the shirt,
which really is worth fucking $8 on a
fucking in the black market.
And then you gotta pay the sneakers,
which are $100.
When I was a kid though,
Texas willow,
I went to union city.
I told him I want to play basketball.
They put you on a team,
they give you a shirt and you played
every week for free.
It didn't cost you anything.
Look at the fucking.
I don't even know about taxes or
anything Joe.
All I know about is when I go buy a
plane ticket and I look at those prices
and I go,
what about the family or to that isn't
doing that well?
Yeah.
What about the fucking,
if I was,
if I was really a tax or have felonies,
I can't vote so I don't even let that
thing on my mind.
What about the $50 I got to pay for
parking when I go to a UFC event?
Yeah.
What about the $184 for a fucking lake?
A ticket with a $100 for a fucking
baseball ticket.
When does it end?
That's what I'm concerned about.
I don't give a fuck about anything else.
I want them to bomb fucking isis now
today.
But everything else for me applies to
the American family that the American
family does not stand a chance in this
country no more.
If your wife works and you have to pay
date care,
what are you bringing home?
What are you clearing after daycare?
Right.
Somebody was telling me for summer camp
in studio city,
it's $200 a week.
That's $800 a month for the average
person.
What's the average person making this
fucking country?
Joe Rogan.
So your taxes are getting used for shit.
I taxes are getting used for shit shit
because they're not going to where
they're supposed to go $800 a month.
It's like,
what is that?
Like 900 $9,600
a year.
So a lot of money,
but for fucking and the girl was telling
me that her son has to volunteer and
help other kids to get that rate city
and I just was telling them,
kindergarten at monarch is 30,
$34,000.
What is in the valley and you know,
don't even mind.
The other two were the daughter went to
school.
I'm like,
ah,
oh.
And by the way,
we're talking about all this.
Like it's a big deal.
If we were living in Manhattan,
there'll
be a goddamn bark.
Was a bargain bargain.
That's what I.
What I think about politics,
I think about people who are fucking
struggling that have two children and
they can't go to a dodger game with a
fucking baseball games you go to.
As a kid.
I can't tell you how many I went to as a
kid.
Yeah.
But with these families cannot afford a
dodger game,
bro.
I'm a fucking savage.
My uncle loves baseball.
He's on old man.
I would go to costco and for $50 I get
two tickets to hotdogs to sodas and a
parking spot.
I don't care about the fucking game.
I take can be 74.
Once magic took over the dodgers,
they don't give you that deal no more.
You don't want.
It seems like.
It's like if you have a giant population
like we do in La and a something like a
dodger take care of someone,
even though it's a giant number of
people,
it's still a small percentage of this
huge population.
I guess they just realize anybody does
this,
realizes he just jack it up higher.
You're going to get a smaller percentage
people,
but there's still enough people,
right?
Exactly.
Like why would we do that?
Let's do that.
Let's just make more and then if you.
You know how it is when you go to a
theater or something like that,
it's got to be twice that.
If there's some sort of a baseball game
or something like that or one of those
huge stadiums,
they about all the people that have to
get paid.
All the people that are working there
while you're working.
They're like giant staff of humans that
have to keep that thing running smooth.
Yeah.
What about the American family that
flies a water?
It's $4 and fifty cents for bottled
water recharging.
I thought water was free.
They give you a cup of water,
a cup of water.
What if and then when you go through
Tsa,
you can't bring the water through.
You can't,
but you can.
You can buy water on the other side of
the sun.
If Joe Rogan you just barely getting by
and you have three fucking kids and it's
$3 a fucking water.
I mean that's the shit that has always
concerned me.
I can break small guy.
The fucking guy that wants to take the
guy that works,
he's divorced.
He pays child support.
He wants to take his kid to a dodger
game and for him to get a ticket,
he's got to sit with gang bangers and
wear a helmet and a fucking nodding God
fucking suit and you know,
you can smoke pot and I just stayed
really.
There's a little section,
supposedly the,
you walk to the left and people's
parking over there.
Is that through?
Let's just pretend that it make it
happen.
Just do it,
man.
If anybody would let it go.
It's La,
right?
Yeah.
He's got more tolerance for weeds and La
is.
Did you see that video?
I don't know where the fuck it happened.
I think it was on the instagram feed.
Clowning the homie.
I don't know if you know that one.
They always have some fun stuff up
there,
but there's a big giant white guy was a
black cop.
Beats the fuck out of them.
Tasers them pizza.
Fuck out of him with a club.
And then uh,
eventually they tasered him from behind.
Another guy got him and he fell and
banged his head off the ground.
And the whole time the guy was saying
like,
I am not fighting you,
I'm not fighting you.
And they're just beating on him with
this fucking that job.
And I've said it a million times is not
for everybody.
And it's one of the most difficult jobs
in the world.
Being a cop.
Yup.
Yeah.
And what we're seeing,
we're seeing that guy that shot that
woman in the alley,
this guy getting beat up by this metal
pipe.
Baltimore cops planting evidence,
plant drugs.
How long have you known me Joe Rogan?
Twenty years.
I did time.
Now they use a verb.
Ever,
ever,
ever heard me say some crazy shit.
Crazy shit.
But you've never heard me say the word
pig.
No,
I have the most respect for police
officers.
It's a small percentage of people.
A stressful job,
but something's going on now.
It's not just stressful.
What about two days ago,
the minutes with the gun to the black
couple,
while he was getting his license and
they kept saying,
please put the gun away and the guy held
the gun.
There is shit.
This is.
And then I love when if they shoot a
black person,
they just get like the black da that go
up there and say,
well we looked at this year,
be up that black metallic cat downtown,
eight cops to beat up a black retard.
And then the fucking kid died.
And they said it's a fucking black kids
fault.
He's fucking retarded.
Eight cops on top of him beating them.
But this goes on constantly and you know
what's going to happen and you fucking
know what's going to happen.
You know exactly what's going to fucking
happen.
Two or three years from now,
all it takes is three angry black guys,
three angry black guys with a surplus to
spread the word.
It was done with the Black Panthers.
It was dunphy is three angry back like
black guys.
And they're going to fucking start going
around in the cities and saying there's
a fire.
And with all these cops show up,
they're going to be on Ruby's.
And they gotta open up on them.
This is going to happen in American
cities.
Some reading happened after Dallas,
Dallas,
that was so don't fucking tell me this
is going to happen.
Three black guys that went through the
service that got weapons,
like I told you,
unless you're retarded,
you can't get weapons to that.
I get,
I get you.
Whatever the fuck you want and
something.
I get you something in an hour,
an hour,
I'll get you something to go fight.
I believe you,
so nevermind.
Assault rifles and shit like that.
That's all you need is five assault
rifles and say that a woman is getting
raped at the end of the fucking a
Cherokee Street and wait for 20 cops to
come and open up on them.
Dogs all headshots,
headshots and leg shots.
That's going to happen eventually
because this cannot continue.
This cannot continue.
I think most people that become cops
have a very difficult time doing it.
I think for some people it's
unmanageable and I think if you think
about all the interactions and all the
police officers have with all the people
all day long,
all across the country,
the vast majority of it is
inconsequential.
It's people,
traffic violations,
little things here and there,
but there's going to be a percentage.
What is that percentage?
Is it even one percent?
I don't know what it is,
but if that one percent gets online,
we focused on that one percent,
so whether it's that guy planting drugs
in Baltimore or these guys beating up
this giant white guy was giant,
but he wasn't threatening them in any
way.
Just didn't want these guys like fucking
danger in them and I think there's just
way
too few people that are capable of
navigating the waters,
the waters of that kind of job.
I think that kind of job is almost.
It's almost as bad or as difficult
rather as a being in the military.
Your life is on the line.
You're at risk all the time.
Constantly.
You know when people will call you a cop
apologists,
if you look at it like that.
Listen man,
if this shit goes down,
someone's breaking into your house,
you're calling the cops,
man.
Okay.
That's what they're here for.
And to pretend that you don't need them
as well.
Okay.
Maybe someday we will,
but right now you need cops for sure,
and definitely they need each other.
They need cops to and they know it and
they and they see it more than you do
because they're the ones who respond to
murderers and armed robberies and rapes.
They're the ones who have to show up and
handle car accidents on the highway
with.
I mean how much special training do they
have that they get to deal with bodies
that are torn apart for how much special
training?
No,
I know.
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure you could even adequately
train a person.
Some people can handle it,
period,
but there's some people they see some
dark shit and they just don't recover
and then you ask those people to just
keep pulling people over and I also
think that they should train the cops a
little more.
I see a lot.
I don't think they have the money.
I say I agree with you.
I agree with you.
I see a lot of dumb shit in La Times.
You're on Hollywood boulevard,
bumper to bumper,
and you go to see what it is and it's a
fucking cop double park.
Given a homeless guy a hard time pull
the carpet.
You pull the car with you fucking
scumbag.
Can't you tell at 4:00
when this fucking traffic?
They don't care.
They don't give a fuck.
You know what?
One day I yelled from the car and they
looked at me.
I yell,
really?
Guys,
eight in the morning,
double fucking parked.
Really no fucking genius here.
And there's smoke coming out of his
mouth while he's screaming,
I'll fucking kill you.
You think I'm fucking kidding me?
I say Shit,
because it's true.
Come on.
It's common sense.
Yeah,
of course.
You want to give me a ticket when we go
to court,
we'll talk about and now we all got
phones now.
We all gotta fucking phones and videos
and the whole fuck.
That's who it's very dangerous.
Is these laws against people filming
cops were.
They're doing shit like you can't have
that.
No.
Is that really a lot of them?
Yes it is.
There are several places where it is
illegal to film cops while they're doing
things.
Find,
make federally.
It's not know for sure.
The police have tried to tell people
it's not,
but I'm pretty sure my spreading fake
news.
I know that they can.
Let's find out if that's the case.
Um,
are there places where it's illegal to
film the cops and know they can tell
you?
Like if there's a situation going down,
I felt like I was lying when I said
that,
that you can,
they can tell you that they need a
certain,
like a bit of space,
but I don't think they can tell you to
stop filming.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
I tried to go to Vegas and there was all
vacation and there were these fucking
smart kids and the cops kept telling
them they had to get off and they would
take,
they would shoot him the cops and
telling them that it was there.
Right.
Here we go.
Taking photographs and videos of things
that are plainly visible and public
spaces as a constitutional right.
And that includes police and other
government officials carrying out their
duties.
However,
there is a widespread and continuing
pattern of law enforcement officers
ordering people to stop taking
photographs or video in public places
and harassing,
detaining and arresting those who fail
to comply the right of citizens to
record the police as a critical check
and balance.
It creates an independent record of what
took place in,
in a particular incident.
Okay.
Well that.
That's.
So that seems like maybe what I was
reading was about people that got
arrested for it.
So the cops were arresting him for but
he doesn't even though it's not really
illegal and they can still arrest you
for a lot of things,
then you go to court and you figure out
the arrest and so if a cop arrest you
for not listening to him.
So like if you're.
If,
if say save a cop is arresting someone
and you're filming it because he's
kicking this guy's ass and you start
filming it and the cop says if you do
not put that camera down,
I will arrest you and they can still
arrest you.
They could say you're obstructing
justice or I would say not to turn the
camera with who's doing something wrong.
Well,
so I got you there.
Right.
It's like fucking hard to stay on the
right path and not go straight dirty
Harry.
If some guy's trying to kill you and
you're,
you know,
you're involved in some situation and
then you see people filming it too.
Fuck man.
I wouldn't want to navigate any of the
shit that cops have to go through on a
daily basis,
but they also have
to clean it up a little bit and when
they do something wrong and we watch it
on film,
they can't tell us that the cop was
justified to do something.
Of course.
Suddenly there was a lot of shit going
on that.
I mean there was 37 murders in Chicago
last weekend.
What did that fuck?
Somebody shooting murder or something
crazy like in those places.
A high level.
But there's a lot of times I've seen
cops act a little too much for what the
situation.
Cause where I grew up in Jersey were
cops come in and they talked to you.
They asked you,
they separate you and they determine if
this was even worth the fucking angle.
These guys today,
they'll come in,
even if we do something at the store,
they'll come into the store and
investigate them for what you do.
Go fucking chase,
chase bank robber.
The day after nine slash 11,
I pulled into fucking seven slash 11 and
a guy had pulled over the line.
Okay.
You know,
was called pulled over the line.
So my car was over the line.
The guy next to me and the whole cars I
pulled in,
I was six inches over a handicap thing
on the Blue Line,
cut and made au turn and came and gave
me a $458.
I understood I was wrong,
but when we just blow up the World Trade
Center.
Yeah.
You ain't got nothing better to do.
You know,
I see fucking Kinky shit all the fucking
time if I'm not involved with it.
So it's got nothing to do with me
copses there's a statistic number that
they have to reach,
right?
Like if they believed that certain
amount of traffic violations taking
place in la,
there's a strong influence on those guys
to write a certain amount of tickets,
whether you'd call it a quota anymore
because I think those things are shawn.
They say they don't have a quota,
but they have something.
They're out there.
There's some severe incentive and if you
don't meet the numbers that they expect
and they in some way shape or form.
Thank you.
Are Not addressing some of the crimes
that are being committed out there.
I'm sure you get a hard time for it.
Listen brother,
when I got arrested in [inaudible] 87,
that detective,
that fucking moron from bolden,
who I liked,
you know,
he got me for four years and he thought
he was fucking what?
You know,
like when,
like when they,
when they locked up,
Godaddy,
the Teflon Don,
he loved you by.
You could have gotten me for 22 years if
you've done your homework.
If that couple is just a little bit,
he would have done 22 years.
You don't know how many times I sat next
to him at the preliminary hearing and
I'm like,
hold this dude doing rug reminds me,
Oh,
you don't like him?
Because he had come to talk to me about
something else,
the same fucking cop a year earlier,
put it together and that would have got
me more in the kidnapping,
so every time I saw this cop I would sit
there at the end.
I would just call them like a big dope
because he was six foot four with the
big chest,
with the bulletproof.
Your thumbing around like you fucking
know it.
You're talking to me.
It's like that fucking kid.
A couple of weeks ago that pushed that
fucking little Mexican hot dog cart.
You'll never hear from him again.
Who?
That little Argentenians dude that
pushed that little Mexican dude with the
fruit cart when talking about.
We're talking about see that Jesus
Christ,
Joe Rogan,
watch lions attacking a monkey,
but you haven't seen somebody that way a
couple of weeks ago with some poor
little Mexican dude was selling hotdogs
on the corner and some fucking little.
He thought he was one of those dudes
with the skinny jeans,
with a guns and roses shirt.
Him and his fat,
white,
ugly fucking girlfriend went up to the
dude and told them to move.
You never saw this.
They told him to move man harassing a
food vendor flipping over.
Oh my God.
Joe Rogan.
Huh?
Look at this fucking jerk off looking
with a dog.
You can tell he's a fucking punch him.
What happened?
Watch.
He told him to move a little speck kid.
Turns out his camera.
Do you want to move it?
Why?
Because he's fucking he.
Well,
he's a skinny Jean guy with that dirty,
filthy white animal.
Have a girlfriend.
So he wants to be a tough guy.
Was Fidel Watch what happens though.
Mexicans through that red pepper right
his fucking face.
And I didn't mind it.
Look,
this is what we're calling the police.
That dude had a pickup and move.
Let me tell you what those colors.
You see those carts with the umbrellas.
How would you noticed a lot more of
those carts that have the rainbow
umbrella?
Thompson,
the girl.
I've seen a few.
You know why?
No,
that the cartel really remember years
ago when you first moved to La,
that was star maps.
What's going on here at the rest of it?
Jamie got it.
Takes off his shirt.
Did they get in a fight after this?
No,
he fucking threw the pepper riders face
the fucking hot pepper.
Tremendous.
He just took his shirt off.
Yeah.
She because he threw pepper in his face.
A little funny.
Still hanging out like right there.
It's weird because they thought the cops
are going to come.
People came to help this little Mexican
dude,
but that dude had to leave town with
this fat fucking disgusting filthy
girlfriend hygiene because you don't run
into those things.
The cartel.
That's why you see so many more voices.
He didn't like it.
They just didn't want them there because
it's like silver lake and he's special.
He's a white dude with the skinny jeans.
Baggy fucking thugged out,
be it.
You know what?
I've known this man.
There's a lot of people that think that
it's okay to be aggressive because
they're in the right,
but didn't you say during the right dog
dog,
ain't nothing going to go down.
That's a pussy.
That dude was a pussy.
That poor kid.
Let me tell you something.
The cocktail brings the coke cup and
fruit.
They chop up the fruit.
Then they sell the fruit.
They don't make.
They don't make a loss.
They have these new umbrellas everywhere
and they have them even across the
street from each other.
They don't sell drugs.
That's what they make the cash drop
offs.
I've had people see him all the way from
San Diego all the way to fucking receive
it.
They're all on the main strips and they
were all confused.
That's why they were around.
She said,
Da,
don't catch them.
They don't drop off drugs.
They just drop off an envelope with a
number on it.
Number eight,
52.
That's where Joe Rogan's number and then
some guy comes that day and it picks up
all the envelopes and it goes right to
instant either and that's the end of the
day.
When we first got here,
we started maps.
That turned out to be a Spanish
prostitution ring.
Wasn't really fucked.
They will fucking those little Mexican
kids up there as they jumped the wall,
the stretch the muffler out white Duke
and fucking Hollywood boulevard.
I got to pee.
I'm trying to hold the center.
You didn't know that.
I know that.
That star maps even made a movie about
it.
What tall star maps really went out
there with the title?
What's the weight?
They made a movie about it.
Yeah,
and this was what you could a bro.
Look at the tagline down there.
If you can read it time.
Carlos wants
to be an actor,
but his father,
pepper one sent me to work in the family
business.
That is male prostitution.
Carlos decides that he will be one of
his fathers boys until he can.
What in the fuck,
man?
Star maps.
I had no idea.
Nineteen 97.
That's great.
That's so nuts.
No idea.
And that's for people that don't know,
that's the people that they sold map to
celebrity homes.
Right.
That was the whole idea of a sunset when
you,
when I first got here in [inaudible] 98,
that was a thousand of those moocs on
sunset.
Fucking uh,
uh,
you know.
Yeah.
And Hollywood and uh,
they're still out there.
They still are,
but just less heroin is involved with
that.
Well,
not,
I don't see the star.
I see the star vans don't see the star
maps.
I don't see the so much better.
I was holding that one crazy man.
Bitch.
Fucking craziness.
It goes fast.
Great things we're do with our lives.
You know what I'm saying?
What are you going to do with our lives?
That's the thing.
Where does it all go?
Man?
Thousand podcasts now was exchanged.
Fucking a society.
You fucking stop.
Changed.
Changed us for sure.
It's a tapping.
All the people thing.
All the people you've had on the
conversations you've had with those
people,
you know,
how much of that would you ever have if
it wasn't for doing your podcast?
No,
it changes you.
It changes the way you think of things.
It changes me for sure.
It changed a lot of the way I think if
things are getting a chance to sit down
with people for hours and hours
uninterrupted,
no phone calls,
no messages,
no text messages,
and to be able to do that on a regular
basis,
you get to know people and like a way
different way.
We don't really get a chance to do that
with each other that often to sit down
and just have no distractions.
Just you and a friend having a
conversation,
laughing,
talking shit about things or the cool
thing is that's the experience.
People are getting listening to it.
That's why you know how much time,
how many times have we been on the road
and we went to a diner afterwards and we
were laughing literally until we in
tears falling down like we were doing
podcasts.
It was just nobody listening to lecture.
Crying and laughing was like the three
of us and some fucking strange.
Nashville,
it's.
I understand.
Totally is what happened today.
It's the same thing.
Exactly.
No,
it's so cool to replicate it left in
that joint over there.
Yeah,
that's definitely more for open those
reefer madness.
I brought another shout out to la speed.
We'd Gina.
Gina was keeping us keeping it strong.
I don't know what they got to do though.
They got to be careful with these
fucking things.
They give these
suspended at an actual glass thing that
the weed comes in and breaks in your
pocket.
Oh,
that's no good.
That's not good.
This one is superior slick.
When you go to a bathroom at a hotel
like a fine.
So they give you glasses in there.
There's two glasses by the sink.
Like what the fuck?
Those pretentious we'd guys.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Well it's clearly an indycar.
Probably the south Americans trained
like a micro dose.
The other side.
It might be BC in my PBC.
Yeah,
sorry.
I'm pretty sure.
Pretty sure.
It's like maybe,
maybe Seattle,
maybe Seattle.
Northwest,
northwest.
It's like basically the good stuff.
Joe.
We motherfucking Dee Wade adrenaline.
Wow.
Podcast.
I forgot there's a show tonight.
We're going to forget a lot of shit
along the way too.
I feel like it's St and pma.
We talked about some shit earlier.
That was the funniest shit ever said in
my life,
but if anybody asks me like,
how is the podcast that I go,
oh dude,
Joey Diaz went on a rant.
It was the funniest fucking thing I ever
heard in my life.
Then he'd go,
what is it about ago?
Couldn't tell,
couldn't tell.
I also couldn't tell you what the last
thing we talked about this or that.
Whatever it is.
I don't know what it is.
It's not that important.
It's not that important,
but these things change us,
man.
I know your,
your podcast,
changing new job,
you know,
it's,
it's connecting you with a most people
that like to come out,
see you in a way that nothing else has
ever had before,
you know?
No.
The biggest thing about the podcast is
keeps me in check,
keeps Punjab substance check.
We got to stick to what we say.
Yeah.
We got to preach what we talk about,
you know,
acute system check,
man.
There's no more.
Uh,
we got somebody watching this now that
you know,
so it's pretty fun.
And interesting to me,
it does keep in check,
but it also,
it's,
um,
ultimately satisfying to,
you know,
to just stay in check,
to like think about what you're doing
and say,
say,
say things that are as accurate as you
possibly know,
be honest about how,
you know,
how you're thinking about these things.
Like where are you drawing your
conclusions from?
Totally.
People don't have a chance to do that
that often.
They don't have to be accountable for
their own thoughts,
you know,
not,
not to the level of like someone who,
uh,
is a hosting a podcast or someone who's
constantly being reviewed by people you
know,
like people do hold you accountable to
do.
They do.
And that's what I like about it.
They showed if I get to do a periscope
in the morning and I tell people I'm
gonna,
go to Jujitsu today,
I get 20 tweets.
Sedna was it?
What did you learn that I didn't go
because Ah,
you fucking pussy to you guys.
Listen Bro.
Let me tell you some good back told.
My mother stopped drinking.
She stopped drinking in 11 days later.
She was dead.
That's why I believe you always got to
have a shot at something.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm not talking about drinking a bottle
at night.
I'm not a big believer in anecdotal
evidence unless it benefits me.
So in that case I'll go with one to two
notes.
Ain't going to kill nobody.
You were saying Dr.
say do this circle.
Let me.
I was so much fun to you.
James.
Motherfucker.
You good sir?
When you drink these things.
Like I said,
it's nothing.
I love the white dudes.
I love white people.
Do you like.
I don't like these like nice white
people they dragged me with.
But what about Charlottesville?
Kinda crazy white people.
But like where do you draw the line?
I like white people who bring a bottle
of Bourbon,
but the most important thing is they
bring a bag of ice because then when you
fucking with that ice,
when a white dude shows up with a bad
guys,
that's a man of class stylists.
Don't put it in the freezer and leave it
right there.
That means they dropped one ice cube in
there every 20 minutes and they got a
time.
That's the whole thing.
Just fuck fucking ice.
Yeah,
I totally agree.
Man.
Dude's house and he's gonna.
Walk in human door.
Filled with cigars.
Do you go,
Huh?
Yeah.
Malone the fuck.
Are you doing man?
What are you doing with your time?
You got a walking human door.
I feel like age is matches up with
cigars in a way that few things do.
Like an old dude with a cigar is like,
I want to hang out with him.
I wouldn't have a drink.
I want to hear what he has to say.
Yeah.
Like a 22 year old with cigar.
I'm like,
get the fuck Outta here.
You feel like you can't have a leather
vest and you're like,
fuck tee shirt with a leather vest.
You don't smoke smoking.
You don't look cool.
Smoking the cigar.
Tony Soprano.
Go turn it over.
You're like,
I need to fucking cigar.
You know why?
I Bet James Gandolfini really enjoyed
smoking a cigar.
He's like actually enjoying the cigar
while he's acting like he's enjoying.
Enjoys the it.
He was a bad motherfucker.
Hell,
you want me to tell you something?
That's the first guy I could say like
doing.
A couple of weeks ago,
I went back to my hotel room,
the fucking original getaway with Steve
McQueen and I forgot,
Bro.
I felt,
God,
you forget your roller.
Look,
I get tears in my eyes.
He's in the dumpster with that bitch.
After the thing,
tripped them over and she's fucking town
them on.
He's like,
well,
we should just break waves.
And she's like,
well obviously you can't get over me
having sex with somebody else or you're
a mental midget.
And Steve Mcqueen,
Bro.
He just grabbed me by the hand and then
he goes back to the whole.
He shoots all those fucking rednecks.
Oh,
we forget how bad.
Steve McQueen.
We'll look at him.
Look at this fucking look at this
fucking man of a man that he was my man
so lot.
So from the Godfather.
Watch Steve McQueen with a fucking suit
on.
This is 1973 dog.
He's so smooth.
This is not the scene you got to put on
the scene is when he beats up.
Allie mcgraw and she thought it was
acting and he just lived.
He pretty much smack the shit outta her.
She didn't know,
but he would smack the shit out of every
other day for some reason or another.
He was like her up.
Yeah.
Seen Bro.
He just had funny,
funny thing.
I'll probably wear it with your listing.
I don't believe in violence towards
women,
but if I wasn't married to Yoko Ono,
you know you gotta kick her once a day,
somewhere in the back and the stomach.
Shut the fuck up sheet.
Look how beautiful this woman was.
Number one,
look at the natural beauty of this
fucking woman and look at this blonde
savage of a man.
Look at him.
He's fucking.
Steve McQueen gets out of the car and he
just starts walking in front of the car.
Does he smack her after this?
He was little.
He had beautiful look at him with his
black suit on and he's furious.
Fight hair.
I wear my hair like that.
Yes.
I will make my head start.
Okay.
Crazy glue.
I figured out,
but you don't want to lose you and put
crazy glue in the morning.
They won't go nowhere.
Now she's getting out of the car.
She looks upset.
It was pretty emotional.
Yeah.
Look at this year,
this 72.
I was not and I went to see this the
first weekend.
My mother goes,
what'd you go see?
Steve McQueen.
Are you fucking crazy?
Wow.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Oh Dude.
He's hitting there for real.
She didn't know she was going to get
hit.
She didn't know.
Oh my God.
Fuck man.
Jesus,
man.
You.
When was the last time you saw this?
You got to see this shit and if you
really want to see a beaten,
you got pull out on the longest year.
I will.
Burt rentals in the beginning when he
grabs her by the throat and hits her
with a bottle of something.
This Berg Grant,
we watched it here,
but this,
this is fucked up because it's crazy
that you,
you know,
he's really hitting her a few times.
He told her.
It's like when Sean Penn did at close
range with with whatever and he kept
shooting a gun and finally Sean Pengos
Gimme the gun because you're not
reacting to the right way.
You're not being scared.
So he shot a real gun at Christopher
Walken,
Christopher Walken,
and talks about it all the time.
Look at this fucking savage.
Go knows the movie.
Opens this shit.
Jesus Christ.
It's amazing.
With 40 years has done.
Yeah.
People use a bb.
How beautiful.
She never seen anything like this
sledding.
Oh,
splitting man.
Look at his body because this guy was
not juicing this guy fucking nuts.
You all American son of a bitch.
This is like a soap opera from Mexico.
This is fucking soap opera from Mexico,
Bro.
Totally is.
So in the seventies,
everybody had Busan that on TV.
Everybody's,
everybody's house had booze me.
So Burt Reynolds got it.
Yeah.
Day.
Well,
well,
wow.
So hostile.
Oh my God.
She bit him.
Oh,
she threw some shit out of him.
This is a Mexican soap opera side.
Jesus man.
Oh,
a fake slapped the guy that was a real
throat.
We'll throw that,
throw the ground seems super real.
That would hurt your hip.
That's a hard floor.
Didn't even give her a cushion man.
Like,
look at what's going on.
Yeah.
There was an actress.
Would you let burt reynolds throw you to
the ground?
No.
Fuck No.
That year dude.
Getting thrown to the hurts that she had
hurts.
Like she just ricocheted off the ground.
One hundred percent.
That wasn't a stockperson often.
This stuff.
Weird question now dog gets into is cost
super weird.
He's got up Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan.
You ready for this?
He gets in his fucking whatever.
He starts it up and all of a sudden you
hear Saturday night,
fucking let it scan it.
Dad.
Uh,
he showed me.
That's all right ma'am.
Did Austin play that part?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
As soon as that,
he gets in his class and that's what's
on the right.
Here we go.
A Burt Reynolds v eight.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Black box.
That's a Maserati.
Levante.
It's.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Wo The cops.
She called the cops.
Whoa.
That car is so fast.
Oh my God.
Meanwhile,
that car handles like total dog shit.
What is it?
I don't know,
but I mean those cars back then.
Even the best ones handled like shit.
That thing as skinny tires.
A fucking caveman suspension.
Well,
it probably did drive a lot better than
those police cars.
Police cars were like the worst cars you
could drive.
Your trying to catch somebody.
They have four doors.
You want a car that has two doors.
That's true.
Sports car.
It's got a good balance and something go
wrong corners quick with you don't like
race.
Cars aren't big long.
Four doors.
That's a lot of extra weight.
It's nuts.
Yeah.
Having a like a police car,
but today they have police cars today.
They're like,
they can make like mustangs.
They turn them into a police car
charger.
Yeah.
Dude,
there's some scary cars today when it
comes to like a a car pulling you over.
Like if the cops have that new dodge
demon.
Have you seen that thing that's fucking
nuts.
800 horsepower.
Zero to 60 in like two seconds.
Really fucking crazy.
Like they can love it.
They make sure it doesn't work.
If it's colder than 15 degrees out Dubai
has the world's fastest police car,
have a Bugatti.
Oh my God.
Two Pie ball in the fall and so strong,
so strong.
I mean if you disrespect bond,
you forget about cultural differences.
You got to respect their ball.
Oh,
divide does it up if you.
If you do it up even a little bit.
I don't give a fuck.
Stop.
Stop making excuses.
They ball harder than anybody.
Yeah.
They have an indoor ski place that you
could have in the desert.
Did He.
Was there a fight there?
No,
but there was a fight in Abu Dhabi and
we did the weigh ins and Dubai.
That's cool.
It was weird,
man.
There's so much money there that was
interested in against Damien Maia.
Yeah.
And Frankie Edgar versus Bj Penn to
like,
I'm pretty sure that we're there to
really have crazy,
crazy money.
I think it's off the charts,
you know,
I think.
I don't think we even understand oil
money.
You know,
what we make.
We think we're doing good these guys,
and it's like many generations of having
that kind of cash.
It's a different level of cash now.
The family wealth,
it gets passed down.
That's where the news is.
Old white money ain't no ganglion that
Jack.
They have interior a surf places too.
We can go surfing.
It's nuts man.
You run a surf board and is that where
the government will give citizens money
that just want to do anything?
Really?
Yeah.
My Dubai,
I thought so maybe I have it wrong,
but my cousin came here to study English
like from Peru,
so he had a class with a bunch of people
from different countries.
I thought he said this classmate from
Dubai will be like,
everybody want to go out on Saturday,
like it's all good and would pick people
up and like limo buses and he's like
wait,
who's paying for this?
And he's like,
oh I got it.
It ain't shit.
And then was telling them like,
he was like,
how we you're just going to pave this?
He's like,
look,
it's just given to me man.
I got to spend all this shit.
I don't even know what the disease is
current.
Just buying everybody drinks,
food,
going to vegas like 15 people.
He just in class with.
Yeah.
Nobody balls harder than them.
It's pretty out of control everywhere he
goes.
Ferrari's,
bentleys,
lamborghinis.
There's like ridiculous.
There's cars that I feel like it would
be ridiculous to show up on one of those
boundaries that they have or one of
those bugattis rather that they have as
a police car for sure.
Since sandy now like two and a half
million bucks so much.
I think floyd mayweather has like six.
He's hilarious.
His habits are hilarious.
I love him.
He's got like a whole list in white.
White is right.
I got a bunch of two though.
Man.
Does gang or cars?
All the money to the irs.
Why don't you just give him.
Because he went so deep so much.
Does he?
Oh,
well.
Uh,
it's more than you want to pay.
It's in the 20 plus million dollar
range.
It's a lot of money,
man.
But it's not something that he's been a.
it's not like deception.
No.
It's just neglect to neglect and it's
also like,
I think there is truth to this.
He makes so much money,
there's probably a point where they're
like,
hey,
it's time to pay your taxes.
And you go like,
all right,
here's a check for $25 million dollars.
That's an incredible amount of money.
And then they go,
that's true,
but you owe 50 more.
And he's just like,
that's,
that can't be right.
I've got $25,000,000.
Yeah.
Like what are you talking about when
he's bought over 100 luxury cars from
the same dealer and always pays in cash
is $15 million worth of cars.
Congratulated.
She doesn't drive.
I like it.
Good.
You can sell those.
They're worth a lot of money.
He can get that money to,
you know,
it's um,
it's just,
it's,
it's really interesting in the amount of
money that he's able to generate,
you know,
he's figured out some pretty incredible
shit.
He's a great villain to man.
He's just brilliant at it.
Mean was just a brilliant defensive
boxer.
Oh,
skill wise.
Off the charts off the truck.
I'm saying that guy should get more
credit for what he does as a skilled
businessman and psychological
warrior.
Like he should get a lot more credit for
it.
Yeah,
I think so too.
I think it's arguable that,
you know,
he's enjoying it and he enjoys playing
the villain role and enjoys like
flashing on the money and if he is
really enjoying it,
like don't you love that and respect
that.
That fucking thing.
What is that car?
That thing looks amazing.
What is it a CCS?
Is that a con of Sig?
Yeah,
I'd say that cone.
That's a word that I've never said a
name,
but I can't say it.
I love too that he starts his post with
the amount.
Like to remind people that my new car.
Yeah,
my new four point $8,000,000
car.
You say that Koenigsegg,
Koenigsegg.
Koenigsegg coincide coding,
coding,
Koenigsegg.
Jesus Christ.
Zec.
That's a ridiculous name.
Change your name,
but the cars dope,
you're saying?
I think so,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
I'm in DC.
Both of working during this fight.
You were headed already recruit.
I already booked way in advance.
Now it's my dad's birthday.
I'm going a big birthday celebration.
You got to try to,
uh,
avoid finding out what happened and then
watching.
No,
it depends,
man.
It,
I haven't.
I don't know.
I'm going to gauge also his interest in
it.
You know,
I always try to get home before I find
out anything or watch it before I find
out anything and I always fail to do so
you'll always,
I cannot give it,
uh,
give me any temptation.
I know it's hard to go online.
Let me check real quick.
Am I worthwhile?
Well,
what if they tell me it's a five round
decision,
you know,
title fight or this one's gonna be 12
rounds boxing and know it's going to be
an exciting event.
It's one of those like you'll remember
like the excitement to tune in.
So I think we are going to want to watch
it.
You know,
conor mcgregor is a magic person.
Yeah.
Like legitimately like to get this many
people so hyped up about this fight.
It's not just about his performances,
his fights.
It's also about like wanting to believe
that there's a dude who can pull it all
off.
Yeah.
It was like a magic person.
Do you feel like in the lead up to the
fight,
like as we get closer,
your opinion on it has changed at all?
Oh yeah.
I'm a sucker for a good hype job,
dude.
That's why I'm a good hype man.
Yeah.
I'm a sucker for believing all that
stupid shit.
I thought Gerry Cooney had a chance
against Larry Holmes when I was in high
school.
I saw Gerry.
Gerry Cooney knockout Ken Norton and was
like,
he might have a chance.
I like,
was it.
Who was the other white dude that was
the great white hope that I think for
Larry Holmes and 82 and he wouldn't make
eye contact.
No,
not Chavala.
June of 82 82.
Oh,
Gelada.
Galana.
So you're talking about and you know.
Yeah.
Know Gerry Cooney is the guy that.
Is that the guy you're thinking of?
The Guy I was talking about,
the guy that.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
That's Gerry Cooney.
That's the guy was talking about some
white dude.
Yeah.
When I was in high school,
I was
who?
Who's the white dude from Bayonne?
That fort.
Oh,
the Bale and bleeder weapon.
Yeah.
I guess he's the guy that they based the
movie rocky on because they didn't
expect him to survive and he kept
surviving.
You kept moving forward and Chuck Wepner
was the guy.
I think that was one of the inspirations
for the movie rocky because that guy
just kept plodding forward and Muhammad
Ali beat the shit out of him,
but I don't think he stopped them.
Damn.
Yeah,
look at that crackers face man too.
He got dropped there.
I get that man.
Muhammad Ali in his prime was so magic,
man.
What he could do as far as movement,
his ability to like move in and out,
slide around.
A lot of people thought he was doomed
when he was gonna Fight Sonny Liston,
like there is no fucking way this kid is
in so much trouble.
All he could do is like box around and
move and move fast.
But Sonny Liston is a murderer,
murderous puncher,
and he got like,
he beat the fuck out of Floyd Patterson.
So like the way he would beat those
guys,
you'd be like,
oh Jesus,
nobody can stand in front of him.
Like very rumbled Johnson,
you know,
maybe even more so in his power.
Yeah.
It was like pitch that it's not taking
place today.
Spot,
you know,
it sucks.
It sucks about not living through an era
is you can never fully appreciate it.
Totally much as you want to know.
Like I already know I've had enough
lessons about Ali,
you know,
but like you're like,
Oh man,
I really wish I would have lived through
it.
Like I already see it now.
I became conscious of it now because of
basketball because people are always
always doing this Jordan or Lebron,
you know,
argument this hypothetical and like you
go back and forth,
but like you real is the first time I
realized there's people arguing who,
who weren't alive during that Jordan
craziness.
And I'm like,
Oh,
you don't know what the fuck you're
talking about right now.
You have no idea what that was like.
You can pull up any statistic you want.
You have to,
you don't.
You don't feel that you didn't watch
that dude become a fucking savage,
like a God damn,
you know,
Spanish conquistador in fucking the NBA
where you could not believe what a
killer.
He was like,
you've never seen that level of
competitiveness and how like how that
dude could dominate.
We've never seen,
but there's people I realized they were
like,
oh no,
I've seen highlights,
and I'm like,
no,
you don't get it.
Like you don't get how dominant he was.
Jordan,
Jordan dominant.
It was the craziest thing ever.
The first time I saw Jordan fly from the
foul line through the air and slam dunk
a ball.
I remember thinking,
how.
How does a person,
how does a person even do that with our
body?
Yeah.
Keith,
he literally flew through the air and
slam dunked this ball and I'm not
exaggerating where it was.
Basically
where the foul line was.
He fucking went flying to the.
An extra step job role.
Bowling favor you put on the top 10 dogs
by Julia survey.
Just one second.
Let's do that and then we'll go to
Jordan.
We'll break it down because before
Lebron,
that was Jordan for Jordan,
there was a guy from long island and
Julia.
Sure,
and he used to kill one team.
The best dunks of all time with done by
him against the Lakers.
Here guys.
This isn't.
This is a regular one.
Okay.
This is nothing.
Okay,
I'll look at that.
This is a guest look.
Watch this on one hand that that's just
your job.
That's super.
Watch this.
Boom and bad.
Over seven foot four and he's six foot
six.
He is against.
Look at this bad.
Okay.
My favorite was Daryl Dawkins destroyed
the Baptist Joe Rogan over a hooker rice
or snorting coke with Darrell bock.
Look at that from the top of the
refrigerator.
Put this back,
but just run this back dog.
He was.
He was going to call my podcast,
but he died three weeks later.
Three weeks before it was a dream.
I went to a psychic.
No,
no,
no.
He did.
That's against bill wall.
Look at this one,
I guess.
I guess that was a watch.
This one is against this guy.
Oh,
watch these tool.
That's beautiful.
The elevation man,
the problem is that's what everybody
wants to say.
You don't want to see all the shit
leading up to the.
It's like when I watched the whole.
This was dramatic.
Hurry up against the trump lexus.
Look at him because he kept calling for
a file.
Look at him,
Bill Walton.
All his shit.
Look it up.
Look up,
bitch.
You're going to be this,
but I'm slamming right in your fucking
face.
He but one was called for a foul.
He know what I feel like if you have a
dishonorable claim at a foul.
If you're doing something like those
soccer players do sometimes,
get this one.
You should lose points.
Look at this one,
Joe Rogan.
There's the one.
I Bet I won.
I had the sixes in Philly.
I guess Michael Cooper is shit.
Keep matching theme.
They gave their hamburgers.
I was down there looking at me.
He was getting they.
We're getting the point that game.
Okay.
Now go to 10 greatest Michael Jordan
dunks about Mike Brown hair yourself for
fucking avatar movie.
Get on the toilet,
getting hit the ball boy for the niche.
Find out a lot about basketball players.
First of all,
do you know basketball players throw
away their sneakers after every game?
It's crazy that a lot of them do.
So he would take the sneakers and sell
them on the.
On the.
Before Ebay he would take the net
sneakers and so look at this crazy shit
man that looked like somebody press
controls and then about he did that.
He has some spectacular air time.
Oh man,
look at this.
He just flies in there man.
I wonder what's like the record
distance?
Yeah.
I know I said from the free throw line,
but what's like the record distances
someone's ever dunked from on top of the
key is way crazier yonker though 18.
It's 18.
It's 15 from the free throw and it's 18
from the top of the key.
Somebody Julia serving.
Oh my.
All the time.
And the things that David Thompson,
he's shaking his head Jamie say saying
no.
As far as anyone's done,
the free throws,
maybe $15.
That's still insane.
But now it's done like a foot or two
behind it.
But have you ever seen Vince Carter's
dunks?
No,
because that dude is 40.
Let's enjoy these first.
Yeah,
these are.
Go to Vince Carter,
but let's enjoy these for a moment
because these are spectacular.
I mean,
Jordan was just another bar in it.
It's a.
it's a beautiful thing because the
planet Thompson would go,
I'm watching 30 for 30 and I want to
call Joe Rogan and call them because I
know he's not that sport.
Like the one about Detroit when they
beat him up really bad ass.
Yeah.
He decided to lift weights.
Trying to get on that maximum.
This ain't ever gonna happen again.
Look at the donkey was when he was done,
but Joe Rogan.
Oh yeah.
He used to wait.
Look at the way he held his hair because
he went and got on.
Really lifted against the Detroit
Pistons,
but Joe Rogan has a basketball
enthusiast and I called Dama wherever.
There's only one the greatest dunked the
ball time and because he jumped over a
motherfucker who did that.
That's what I'm talking to Joe.
You Got Mad ally Drexler Against
Louisville.
Nineteen 81,
right?
Right,
right.
Against the wizards or dunk and Houston
was called five slamma Jamma because
that's all they did was dunked.
There's a few athletes that I feel like
even from our era you could bring to
today and there will be super
successful.
Like Marvin Hagler is one of them.
I feel like I'm going to go get ready.
Boom.
No,
that's not the ones are that.
That's not the one.
No.
There's a few athletes that I think you
could take today and they would be super
successful.
Like for short,
Julia Surveying for sure.
Michael Jordan for sure.
For sure.
Magic Johnson for sure.
You know,
no matter what,
like you bring them into this era where
there'll be successful in almost any
area.
I'll never forget I was at a ball.
What Vince Carter did.
I was at a bar one night and there was a
Cuban dude and he was passed out like
this.
Joe Rogan.
Can you find the video?
Joey?
Have the do the.
He jumped over the dude.
I've never seen it.
It doesn't look,
but look at this shit.
What's this?
This is Vince Carter.
Oh my God.
It's amazing.
He rubbed his nuts on that dude's head
washed out again.
Watch this.
He rubbed his nuts on that detail.
Tell.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
He went over that do 10 just do to still
dumps like this and he's 40.
That's insane.
That's an athlete.
When we were in high school,
he was in high school for a minute,
close to us.
I jumped over that guy.
They would show his high school
highlights on local news like it was.
They would cover it like an NBA game.
Dude,
look,
I know he's rubbing his tick on that
guy's ear.
Watch while you fucking my fucking is
fucking face,
right?
He said mind fucking them directly
through the ear and then slams that.
That's insane.
Yeah.
No,
Roy Jones Jr was like that.
Oh yeah.
Roy Jones Jr in his prime,
had some athleticism that didn't even
make sense.
He was able to land a lead left Hook
instead of a jab or a lot of guys shot
in a jab.
Roy Jones Jr.
He like most of the time,
lead with a lead left hook.
WHoa,
jesus.
I got to fly around the rim and dunk.
That's the arman rim dunk.
Ladies and gentlemen.
It's much more difficult than the right.
Think about a.
You've got to worry about breaking your
arm.
Thompson had a 48 junk vertical way
inch.
I think about that.
That was 30 years ago.
I can't imagine the kind of vertical
jumps.
College player.
I got to be up to 60 slash 55 inches.
those defensive backs.
michael irvin,
michael,
wherever we could jump four feet in the
air.
Yeah,
that's how he became like a one one.
He's afraid because the giants with the
blonde hair back.
I see him at jake waves.
Just put.
Ain't no bigger than here though.
A old though.
Back then it was not that much bigger
than jake.
Glaser's got a hell of a gym.
Huh?
I saw stallone was working out there
with chocolate dal's.
Like what kind of chris you have?
You go see that.
Football players.
Fighters all day long training.
Um,
what's it called again?
A something optimum performance and
breakable.
Breakable.
Yeah.
The oWner is a man.
Good move on his part.
He wasn't back up from chicago.
That's a,
that's a smart move,
you know,
be a part of some sort of a cool
strength.
We don't look at that dog.
This is a brand hand.
Well,
athletes are always getting better,
right?
If you go back to baseball from the 19
fifties and then go to baseball in 2017,
it seems better and better.
Athletes,
you're seeing people that are Just
faster,
smarter,
trained,
better use,
better nutrition.
They're optImizing themselves the best
they can.
The question is like,
I wonder like genetically what's
happening?
I wonder if like people genetically are
getting bigger and faster.
I wonder if it's like a little slight
uptick that will one day maybe 20 years
from now,
30 years now registering in a big way
because you've got to wonder with all
these people competing in crossfit and
all the strength and conditioning stuff,
people's bodies might start literally
thinking they have to work harder again.
They have to get stronger and bigger.
Again,
people might get bigger.
This is my terrible understanding of
genetics as applied.
I'm sold on it.
Just on that alone.
The public peer reviewed pApers did.
I've spent the cub dog.
I'm waiting,
I know the thRee weeks I spit in the
cup,
just hit home related to.
I did it.
The mr.
Com,
do you see that thing about all those
white racists were found out they were a
black people in their past and then they
credit the test for that reason.
You know who you can taLk shit about
because if you find a certain percentage
like I could talk shit about italians.
Sure.
Because I'm mostly italian.
Yeah.
You know,
so most people wouldn't consider it a
bad thing when you move.
Silliness got raped by the noise and
then the more and then the sicilians one
night on the night of the vest was in
1600 got up and they cut the dick off
and shoved them in their fucking mouth.
That's why you can't talk about rape and
for the most resIlient.
Neither the vespers is an old sicilian
tradition to go.
That's why those sicilians or go with
knives.
Crazy.
Now millions of go with knives.
They tell you,
keep them at arm's distance.
Would olsher chileans don't fuck with
them because they got those knives that
go with those knives and shit.
It's crazy.
Cubans.
My sister's dark skinned and then I look
at my cousin who's my skin and his
sister.
The singer is dark skin show.
I know there's some african shit in my
fucking blood.
It's Cuba.
Who's um,
what's the band's name?
X alfonso.
Aggie.
Aggie band.
the band or in excel?
Phonto.
Is that it?
His name is becky and her name is emma.
I've got it on my phone.
If you ever go to his cousin's cousin,
amazing band.
Really do.
They're really,
really good.
But they the fuck the ria.
So yeah,
here iT is.
X alfonso,
back to my mail.
Gimme some gimme some volume on this
shit.
They're really good dude.
I mean no bullshit.
Listen to this on my way to the comedy
store all the time.
I get pumped up because I don't know
what the fuck they're saying.
So just for me just feels good.
It's like celebratory and I get into my
own head thinking about my material.
I get pumped up listening to this night.
you sent me a video you were looking at,
you were listening to something else
like italian music.
I always do that.
Yeah.
I always listened to language that I
don't understand.
So you don't think about the words?
Yeah,
I don't think about the words at all.
See,
this doesn't.
I don't understand what this is and
there's.
There's ignorance in it,
but there's also a freedom.
So freedom is that I can hear the
beautiful sound of his voice and not
have any context to it.
No,
no.
Like whatever his messages or anything
and I can have it in the background and
100 percent concentrated on what I'm
trying to do and just enjoy it.
And it's like an instrument.
Yeah.
Like if you like listening to a,
a shooting star by bad company,
you johnny was a schoolboy when they
heard his first beatles' song.
That's going to change the way you feel
like you hear about that.
If you're writing about a certain thing,
you're not gonna be able to concentrate
on your subject.
I think it was from there.
It didn't take him long and when I was
in high school,
everybody wanted to be that guy.
Everybody wanted to be that bright star
that burnt out,
didn't fade away,
and everybody's like,
man,
we lost johnny.
When he goes,
I love when he goes,
don'T you know,
you know that you fucking tremendous.
It's great fucking mail.
Yeah,
I'll look at his sister if you scroll
down,
show him my sister.
So my whole family is like this with the
male is light skin,
but my sister is dark skin.
I just said fuck it.
I got it.
And then some other kids sent me
paperwork that I was related to some
italian navy guy called Louis Diaz from
ninth to from 1832.
So I said,
enough with this shit,
let me just spit in a cup.
Plus it also tells you where your
genetics guy and what you might die of
what you might get cancer have.
You might have cardiovascular disease.
It tells you what your family did a
family reunion in 2000 and they hired
this genealogy expert and they thought
like this would be like the big
culmination on saturday.
Who to present a family history that
everybody in the family.
It's like 30,
40 people there this weekend.
No,
no,
no.
This was in the year 2000.
And then that guy started telling us
about this,
uh,
our first guy that came over from Spain
and then where he landed and like 17,
20.
Everyone's like,
oh,
that's cool.
And then he was just like,
he was a real piece of shit and like he
killed somebody and he went to,
he went to prison and then he,
he was stealing from people and when he
died he left 60 slave to this person and
everybody was like,
well,
let's go have dinner now.
Yeah.
Hey,
we're baffled.
Every baffles me because diaz is a
cuban.
Yeah.
And then there's the diaz brothers that
are mexican,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
So that means our relatives came from
Spain spraying.
we went to an island and the other one
went through Mexico through somewhere.
And I look at those deals,
brothers and like,
well I got this guy.
We're both with the of us retarded.
There's got to be some type of blood
that we shed because we're not all bad,
you know what I'm saying?
But there's also a d as in puerto rico.
Right?
And that's a different kind of ds.
Then the mexIcan ds to,
you know,
it's,
it's really interesting once you hear
enough spanish and you hear the
difference between like being friends
with you and listening to a lot of cuban
people talk like cuban people have like
a very certain rhythm and then puerto
ricans have like a different kind of
rhythm and mexicans have their own
rhythm.
All differenT changes.
Man.
the funny thing about hanging out with
thomas,
people look it up and he looks like a
brosky from like Wisconsin or something.
They don't
realize he speaks fluent spanish.
So people will talk shit in spanish in
front of you all the time.
about me sometimes.
Yeah,
all the time.
They would never guess what,
what,
what happens when you drop it on them?
It depends,
man.
Like,
uh,
sometimes you get a,
like a big,
you can see the shame wash over them,
you know,
they say something rude at the end.
I'll say like,
have a nice day.
I think like,
I hope you have a great day rest of your
day.
And they're like.
And then sometimes they laugh,
sometimes,
you know,
I've had it go even.
I remember in high school my cousin came
from Peru and we went into,
it was the reverse.
We went into a gnc.
Yeah,
we were like 14.
And I go in spanish because he's
visiting.
I tell them just places easy to steal
from.
And then I don't realize that the,
uh,
the lady working at the store was
spanish,
so instead of she just let us kind of
look around and then,
and then she started speaking us in
spanish and we were like,
oh,
we thought we were speaking to some
crazy code,
you know,
like,
this isn't fucking,
you know,
farsi that you're going to run into a
lot.
It was spanish,
but it happens all the time in.
They also,
I also realized it's probably,
I don't know if it happens to you
because I don't look spanish.
A lot of times spanish speaking,
people don't want me to speak spanish to
them,
was that if they're here,
they're,
they're not appreciating that you're not
letting make,
letting them show you that they could
speak english.
A lot of times that's,
it
just tanked because americans wouldn't
give a fuck if you were over in Italy
and so started talking english and you
had like one of those translators you
trying to like,
um,
yo soy,
try to talk to him and he just started
saying,
no problem.
I speak perfect fluent english.
Thank god it's just talking here.
It's different though.
You would never be like,
oh,
let me struggle sometimes to somebody
that I speak way better spanish than
they speak english real.
It's still insist on keeping it english.
That's rough.
It gives them like with me,
they look at me for a minute and then
once I start going off.
Yeah,
like those.
Hello?
Como?
Anybody could say those?
Yeah.
It's when they asked me,
how's your day going?
Like when somebody spanish system and
get that,
I always say I eat for how long
[inaudible] been compounded and they
look at me and I tell them I'm here
fighting with these fucking white people
on a day and they look at me and go,
oh,
okay.
He's okay.
But the guy at the weed store at
cushman.
Yeah,
they used to be a little security guard
and I didn't say nothing to him.
He never looked at my name.
He would just look at joey or something
and he would go away that go the ate the
fat italian,
just let him roll for like eight times
and one day I said,
oh yeah,
you're going to feel and look at that
particular pet or the normal are porter
and his face turned back like he had a
gun and everything and he got paid
because they said,
never disrespect me and I'll never
disrespect you.
You son of a bitCh.
He just turned pale a week.
Ladies,
I come in,
I'm going to get you discounts on weed
up in the valleys.
Sure,
sure.
Because he.
I lived in hollywood at the time,
but I would catch people,
but it's really weird.
Yeah,
some people don't.
Some people don't.
Some people are cool with it.
Dude,
you ain't seen somebody kill until you
seen joey diaz do half spanish.
Half english in miami at the improv.
I bet in 2004,
2000.
Three,
2004.
When that place was crazy.
Crazy.
either one.
I could go off.
I'm sure I could go.
Was really funny in spanish.
People get grades I imitate is the
people that you know.
I grew up around the cuban guys I grew
up around with.
Very funny.
I was telling a friend of mine,
he that was bartending in highschool,
adequate highschool and bartend and
there was this bookie that hung out
there.
His name was our nardo and he didn't
speak no english and I used to talk to
him.
He was a cuban do built.
We had a big,
big gut and one day he was sitting on a
chair like this and my buddy was joked
and he's telling them about your yo yo
come by.
And he goes,
I gotta go.
My friend goes,
what are you going to go home?
We didn't even speak spanish or nardo.
He goes,
well,
and my friend goes,
what he talking about?
I never forgot nardo was sitting in a
bar chat and go back and he just started
going,
oh,
well when I go home now,
forget it.
And they started making believe like he
was jerking off and he would make the
noises.
I have never been to.
This bar is looking at a decade now,
but he's going,
I wouldn't,
he would come,
he would pop back in the chair and go,
blah,
blah.
The whole fucking bought fucking.
And then he would sit back and go,
oh,
you're living.
Yes,
I bought.
He would play out the whole thing.
Jerking off hands.
Oh,
the people you run into in your daily
life.
If you do that today,
they'll put you in jail.
I,
uh,
have you.
If you do that today,
have you leaned back in a bar and start
jerking off into the sky?
Oh my god.
Didn't put you in jail.
That's sexual assault just to do the
impersonation.
I'm sure didn't jim morris and getting
in trouble for that?
He pulled his dick out.
He pulled his dick out of my la.
Yeah,
it was.
He pulled his dick out.
Famous concert.
But I thought that during mr.
Mojo rising,
he would make believe he was whacking
off when he got arrested.
I think,
uh,
our boy who got arrested,
the comedian for doing something on
stage,
like a sexual something.
Which guy?
The original guy,
lenny lenny did.
I think he just got arrested for
talking.
I don't think he ever pulled his dick
out.
I think that.
I'm not saying it was thicker.
I mean like doing the motion.
Oh,
maybe.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
We definitely get prosecuted for
profanity.
Was iT sam?
Jim morrison's.
Many of the,
nearly 12,000
youths said they found the bearded
singers exhibition,
disgusting,
including included in the audience were
hundreds of [inaudible] escorted junior
and senior high school girls.
Morrison appeared to masturbate in full
view of the audience,
screamed,
upset idis,
and exposed himself.
He also got violent slugged,
several and in parentheses,
concert promoters and through one of
them off the stage before he himself was
hurled into the crowd with his dick
hanging out.
Wow.
Interesting.
He says to this day,
Morrison's bandmates denied this version
of events as a guitarist.
Robby krieger explained the spinner.
They were complaining about jim whipping
out onstage,
which he didn't do.
500 photos were entered as evidence that
trial and not one of them showed
anythIng of the sort.
Regardless,
after rejecting a plea bargain,
the singer was found guilty of
misdemeanor counts of indecent exposure
and open profanity and sensitive
sentenced to prison time and find the
case was on appeal at the time of his
death.
July third,
19,
71.
Wow.
Interesting.
And cleMency board in 2010 voted to
pardon the singer more than 40 years
later.
I'm who the fuck those would happen if
they don't have a picture of his dick
out.
I thought they had a picture of it.
If they don't have a picture of his dick
out,
somebody could have yelled his dick's
which is just like yelling fire in a
crowded building.
He started hearing thing at the end of
the la woman,
ms dot mojo raja,
and then at the end he would make
believers rise.
Rise route.
whoa.
Yeah.
Maybe to them it looked like
masturbation to him.
It looked like he was playing like an
air guitar.
Right?
He pretended to jerk off.
Yeah.
Maybe you're not allowed to do that back
then.
Really?
I would deny like a good 40 percent of
all of our material.
It's a lot of it.
If someone told you you can't fake jerk
off on stage of life,
am I going to make this bit work?
There's a couple of specials that are
gone entirely.
Fuck.
That was one of my best ones.
Shit broke it.
They edit out all the stroke and their
parts.
You'd be like,
oh,
I'm so limited in my game.
God dammit.
Get the fuck out of here.
What the fuck?
Joe diaz.
It's only three and a half hours into
the show.
I got to pick the baby up.
Listen,
this is one of my favorite times ever.
Oh mY god.
I'm going to have to review it and find
out what the fuck you said.
That made me laugh until I literally
couldn't breathe.
But,
uh,
to everybody that's been on the show.
Thank you.
Thank you to everybody listening.
Thanks to all everybody from top to
bottom.
I love the fuck out of you.
People more to come.
and,
uh,
tom seger and christina,
visit skis,
your mom's house,
one of the best podcast on the internet.
Of course,
church.
What's happening
now?
lee siad the fly and jew and the great
joey coco diaz available on everywhere.
And that's it.
Thanks.
We'll see you more.
Ready to go for hours?
Everything tonight.
All right.
We love you guys.
Thank you.
Love.